1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
Schönen guten Abend, 22.06 Uhr, das ist das Chaosradio 51.
Genau.
Im Studio Hans, Tim, Rob und Philipp. Philipp hat kein Mikrofon, darum wird der heute nicht zu hören sein. Nein, das funktioniert nicht. Also wir haben nur drei Mikrofone auf unserer Seite.
Ja, dann sollten die sich das...
Ja, natürlich teilen könnt ihr euch das dann irgendwann. Das basteln wir dann gleich so.
Chaosradio.
Wir machen hier noch ein bisschen Chaos. Möchte jemand sagen, worüber wir heute reden wollen?
Ja, aber dieses Gerät, was nicht funktioniert...
Aber es sieht geil aus. Es sieht aber echt geil aus. Und ich möchte es haben.
Das ist ein Gadget-Punkt.
Es resetten sich permanent.
Ja, sag doch wenigstens mal, wie es heißt.
Heißt es, Drahtlose Netzwerke mit hoher Geschwindigkeit.
Das irgendwie Do-What-I-Mean-Gerät, aber derzeit tut es genau das nicht.
Außerdem wollen wir ein bisschen über Internet und Flatrates und so fabulieren und was man damit noch alles machen kann.
Genau.
Neue Bürgersteige auf dem globalen Dorf.
Im globalen Dorf.
Das macht mich ganz nervös.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich das bin, der dich nervös macht, sondern dein 1000 Marks Equipment, was du hier mitgebracht hast.
700.
Ja, und die Karte.
Aber die funktioniert, ne?
Du hast Netz, weil du dir das Internetkarte gekauft hast. Ich mache dir hier schön den Nat-Demon und dann ist gut. Dann natte ich dich hier auf mein Interface.
Ah, du machst eine Base-Session auf.
Nein, ich mache keine Base-Session, wir machen ad hoc. Und ich mache dir Nat auf meinem Internet-Interface und dann ist Ruhe im Karton.
Ja, vielleicht sage ich derweil einfach mal ein bisschen was in unserer und eigener Sache. Das ist heute du ad hoc.
Ich regle das jetzt mal runter, das hat ja keinen Wert hier mit euch beiden.
Das ist heute das letzte Chaosradio, das an einem Mittwoch stattfinden wird. Darf ich eure Mikros jetzt wieder aufmachen? Warte mal, wann mache ich denn Mikros wieder auf?
Ich will die gleichen Bandbreite haben wie du auch.
Ich glaube, ich habe per se schon eine etwas größere Bandbreite. Also das ist das letzte Chaosradio, die 51 heute, die an einem Mittwoch stattfinden wird. Wir wechseln auf den Montag mit dieser Sendung. Das heißt, es findet an einem Tag statt, wie Tim eben so treffend bemerkt hat. Das ist mir vorher gar nicht aufgefallen. Das ist vorher an einem Woche stattgefunden. Das heißt, am letzten Montag im Monat wird es fortan Chaosradio geben. Und vielleicht habt ihr euch gesammelt soweit, sonst mache ich noch mal ein bisschen Musik. Und wir versuchen es gleich nochmal.
Also ich habe auf jeden Fall noch kein Netz.
Ja, ich mach dir jetzt gleich den Nat. Aber jetzt reden wir erst mal ein bisschen Deutsch. Network Address Installation.
Ah ja, das verstehe ich auch. Ihr könnt euch jetzt übrigens dieses Mikrofon teilen. Das heißt, Rob muss aufstehen.
Aber ob du könntest meinen Barhocker haben, weil ich stehe sowieso, wenn du sitzen möchtest.
Welche Barhocker?
Na, hier waren vier Barhocker.
Habt ihr Getränke mitgebracht?
Ja, du hast sogar schon eins zu kommen.
Verdammt, also hier steht noch ein Barhocker, den könnt ihr auch noch haben.
Und funktioniert das nicht?
Nee, das ist... Warum funktioniert denn das?
Nee, das funktioniert nicht. Das Thema, lass uns doch nicht so am Thema vorbei reden.
Wir reden nicht am Thema vorbei, wir reden noch nicht mal ansatzweise dran.
Genau, von vorbei zu reden wäre vermessen.
Ja, allerdings.
Komm, wir machen noch ein bisschen Musik und sammeln uns noch ein bisschen.
Und dann sagen wir, was das Thema ist. Genau.
Am besten heute geht es um ein Zweierlei. Heute geht es um ein Zweierlei. Einerseits wollen wir so ein bisschen den aktuellen Flatrate-Hype mal ein bisschen analysieren, was dahinter steckt. Alle erzählen derzeit, na wie immer eigentlich, dass Internet jetzt super billig zu haben ist. Und wir erzählen auch, warum wir Flatrate generell schon eine tolle Idee halten und warum das, was heutzutage für Maschinen als Flatrate bezeichnet wird, nicht unbedingt unseren Qualitätsansprüchen genügt. Und dann wollen wir ein bisschen darüber fabulieren, mit was für einem Heimequipment man sich denn heutzutage so state of the art ans Internet anbindet. Und vor allem wollen wir über Wavelarn reden, was eigentlich ein Produktname ist. Die eigentliche Bezeichnung ist Ieee 802.11, bzw. 802.11b. Das ist der Standard für Ethernet über Luft, also mit ohne Kabel. Und damit kann man halt sehr schön kleine Heimnetze aufbauen, bzw. sich auch letztlich ohne Nutri gekommen Kampi ans Netz anbinden. Darum geht's.
Darum geht's. Dann fangen wir mal an mit Flatrate, weil ich hab mir nämlich eine geholt. Da klebten überall Plakate, da stand drauf Sonne. Und da hab ich mir gedacht, wie der so ein kack Stromanbieter. Und dann war irgendwie bei Heise so ein Banner eingeblendet. Und dann dachte ich mir, Moment mal, die blenden doch keine Stromwerbung da ein. Hab da mal drauf geklickt, ja, ich hab ein Banner geklickt. Ja, und jetzt bin ich in den Fängen. Aber so schlimm finde ich das nicht. Also wenn die sich an das halten, was in den AGB steht, dann ist das irgendwie gar nicht so schlecht, hatte ich den Eindruck.
Naja, ich meine, die versprechen hier halt nichts. Aber günstigerweise ist es bei Sonne zumindest so, dass sie dich halt in den Jüjü-Network-Bron reinlassen und der ist eigentlich relativ gut ausgebaut. Also man kommt da relativ gut um die Werte. Die in der deutschen Anbindung ist teilweise nicht so prall, aber man kann das schon ganz gut benutzen.
Ja, so für den Mist, den ich zu Hause da mache, das ist völlig ausreichend. Vor allem ist eben das Schöne, dass du eine monatliche Kündigungsmöglichkeit hast. Und das ist das Tolle. Also, die online oder was es da alles gibt, da musst du dir dann direkt wieder für ein Jahr dich verpflichten. Das ist ja auch nicht so angenehm.
Was eben genau vor dem Hintergrund der Vertragsbedingungen total aulich ist, dass du dich dafür ein Jahr verpflichten musst. Und dann sie dir aber in den AGB genau gar nichts versprechen, außer dass es vielleicht funktioniert. Aber noch nicht mal das so richtig, sondern mehr so, naja, wir geben uns mit.
Was ich besonders auch sehr sympathisch fand, die haben dann natürlich wieder fett Werbung gemacht und haben dann ihre Einwahlarchitektur ein bisschen unterdimensioniert. Das habe ich dann die ersten drei Tage richtig zu spüren gekriegt. Ich habe dann da angerufen, die Leute an der Hotline zusammengeschrien und die Pressestelle verlangt und so. Und die haben das dann aber allen Ernstes gebracht und haben auf ihre Homepage geschrieben, ja, ne, wir nehmen jetzt erstmal keine Leute mehr an, sondern bauen lieber mal unser Netz aus. Und sobald das wieder geht, melden wir uns wieder. Und haben dann auch wirklich ein Mailing gemacht an alle bestehenden Kunden, die die schon hatten und gesagt, hier benutzt bitte die Einwahlnummer, die ist neu, die ist besser, die ist schneller, die ist nie besetzt. Und seitdem funktioniert das richtig gut.
Ja, also was sehr schön ist, zu sehen ist, dass mittlerweile die Idee der Flatrate aufgegriffen wird. Was versteht man eigentlich darunter? Flatrate heißt, Internet kommt zu einem festen Tarif oder zu einem festen Betrag zum Festpreis nach Hause. Nur, dass jetzt sozusagen die Auffassung darüber, was sozusagen für diesen Festpreis geliefert wird, sehr unterschiedlich ist. Wenn man eine normale Modem-Leitung benutzt oder benutzt hat, oder eben auch ISDN, bespricht das Gerät, was irgendwie dieses Modem bedient, mit dem Internet-Service-Provider PPP, dieses Point-to-Point-Protokoll, wo halt immer eine neue Adresse ausgehandelt wird. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo die Verbindung hergestellt wird, bekommt man eine neue IP-Adresse. Das ist zwar eine tolle Idee, wenn man sowieso nur einen Computer zuhause hat, und dann so ein bisschen rumsurft, und dann war's das wieder. Aber eigentlich will man ja richtig Internet machen. Und richtig Internet heißt, man hat halt auch zuhause ein Netz. Denn Internet ist ja das Netz der Netze. Und wenn ich zuhause ein Netz habe, will ich nicht nur einen Computer, mit dem ich surfe, ins Netz bringen, sondern ich möchte halt meinen Netz Teil des Internetzes werden lassen. Und das Wichtigste, um dieses zu erreichen, ist natürlich ein im Netz auch gültiger und korrekt gerouteter Adressraum für meine Computer, sodass jeder Rechner eine eigene Adresse hat. Wenn man nun zu so einem Provider geht und sagt, gib mir mal für 770 Mark Netz, und ich hätte ganz gerne auch noch 16 Adressen für meine Computer, dann schauen die einen halt an mit so einem ganz mitleidungswürdigem Blick und sagen, entweder wir verstehen nicht wovon du redest, ich wollte gerade sagen, die sagen gar nichts. in irgendwie 19% weiteren Prozent sagen sie wahrscheinlich, ich verbinde sie mit unserem Techniker, und 1% mit unserem Techniker.
Ja, dann müssen sie unsere gebührenden züchtige Technik-Hotline anrufen.
Genau, also mit anderen Worten, das Problem ist, dass die Leute, dass die Provider bislang nicht so richtig viel Lust hatten, einem wirklich eine Standleitung zu geben, also eine dauerhafte Verbindung zum Netz, entweder, wenn sie so einen Flatrate-Tarif gemacht haben, klappen sie einmal am Tag die Verbindung, oder vielleicht auch noch kürzer.
Ja, häufiger.
Das kommt auf den Anbieter an.
Ich glaube, Sonne macht das recht häufig, also um die vier bis sechs Stunden habe ich so den Verdacht. Ja, ja, das ist, also wenn dann der normale User versucht, sich da irgendwie bei Netscape oder so etwas downzulohnen, dann hat er ein Problem, dann macht er das nämlich jedes Mal wieder neu.
Also es ist ja vor allem macht irgendwie keinen Disconnect so richtig. Keinen? Also ich weiß ja nicht, weil meine Leitung überhaupt mal aus ist, aber...
Du nimmst ja vor allem, was kostet es?
Das kostet jetzt immer noch 140 Mark.
Und dafür gibt es was?
Dafür ist halt die Online-Anbindung und in Ordnung.
Kein Problem.
ESDN, ein Kanal?
Ein Kanal, und wenn man einen zweiten dazuschalten will, dann muss man halt nochmal 140 Mark pro Monat bezahlen.
Und auch dynamische IP-Adresse? Ja, das ist halt sozusagen das, was kostet.
Die machen die dynamische IP-Adresse natürlich, weil wenn die das nicht machen, dann hat so die Hälfte der Benutzer innerhalb zwei Monate wohl ein Napster-Server auf. Und dann fliegen da viele Bits übers Netz, und das wollen die nicht haben.
Der springende Punkt bei den Flatrates ist ja, dass das so eine Mischkalkulation ist. Das heißt, die gehen davon aus, dass sie Tausende von Kunden haben, die das eigentlich gar nicht wirklich ausnutzen. Und dann die wenigen vielen Nutzer, die tatsächlich ihre Leitung auf Volles Worm benutzen, dass die da nicht so ins Gewicht fallen. Bloß, wenn jetzt alle eine feste IP-Adresse hätten, würde jeder seinen Web-Server und seine Musik und wissen schon.
Das ist auch glaube ich der große Vorteil dabei. Also bei diesem 80 Marks Ding ist auch für mich jedenfalls, ich kann eben einfach mal, weiß ich nicht, aufs Klo gehen, oder in die Küche gehen, mir ein Brot schmieren und muss ich, der Ticker läuft nicht.
Ja genau, das ist so der psychologische Ticker.
Ja eben, das macht echt Spaß.
Wenn du das Mikrofon näher an den Mund ranmachst, dann kann man dich auch besser verstehen.
Der Schreckaufwachtern im Bett, habe ich die Leitung ausgemacht.
Eine Nacht immer gleich 40 Mark wegsausen, richtig scheiße.
Ich muss ja mit meinem Laptop aufpassen, ich habe immer den Trend irgendwie gegen die Rollspannkaste zu drücken, dann sind wir komplett aufgeladen.
Das klingt dann wie ein Handy ohne Empfang mehr.
Ja, ich meine, mit dieser dynamischen IP, das ist halt eigentlich bäh bäh. Weil man will dauerhaft am Netz sein. Viele Leute verstehen ja nicht, warum das eigentlich wichtig ist. Das ist halt dann wichtig, wenn man wirklich mit anderen Computern, die irgendwo über das Netz erreichbar sind, permanent arbeitet. Also ganz normalen Telnet-Verbindung hat es, wenn ein Computer eingeloggt ist, dann möchte man natürlich auch morgens aufwachen und dann besteht diese Verbindung immer noch.
Man will eigentlich auch 34 Megabit nur für sich nach Frankfurt.
Nein, nach Berlin.
Das Problem ist nur, dass das Internet in Deutschland noch zu teuer ist. Die Bandbreite hier ist im Vergleich mit Amerika oder auch im Vergleich mit Amsterdam, ist einfach noch viel zu teuer.
Naja, ich meine, das Problem ist eben tatsächlich, dass die Abrechnung zwar zu den Kunden entweder zeitorientiert läuft oder ein Pauschaltarif wie bei den Flatrates, dass aber die Internetprovider untereinander half Gigabytes abrechnen. Und selbst wenn man sehr gute Tarife hat, kriegt man einen Gigabyte nicht unter 30 Mark. Na gut, es gibt vielleicht irgendwie noch Leute, die wirklich ganz viel abnehmen und dann noch ein bisschen billiger sind. Aber gängiger ist 60 oder 90 oder 150 Mark. Das sind so Gigabyte-Preise. Und dann kann man sich ja ausrechnen, wenn man einen 64 Kbit Link hat, also einen ESDM-Kanal, wie schnell dann Gigabyte zusammenkommt und wie schnell da eben reelle Kosten für den ISP auch anfallen. Da geht es dann plötzlich mit der Flatrate, dass das gar nicht mehr so realistisch, sondern es ist eine Mischkirpulation, die ja so ganz komisch ist und wo man sich nicht wundern muss, wenn der eine oder andere Flatrate-Anbieter noch in Probleme in finanzieller Art kommen wird, wenn er zu gut ist.
Und dann eben so Nachforderungen stellt, wer war das jetzt? Da war doch jetzt ein Flatrate-Anbieter, der jetzt irgendwie seinen Laden dicht gemacht hat, weil es nicht ging und dann erst mal noch Rechnungen rausgeschickt hat und gesagt hat, ja ihr habt das ja alle gewerblich genutzt, ich bezahle mal 6.000 Mark nach.
Ja, in diese Problematik begibt sich natürlich jeder, der solche Flatrate-Verträge mit so komischen Vertragsbedingungen unterschreibt, weil da steht dann halt drin, du darfst das nur alleine benutzen und du darfst das nur benutzen, um irgendwie alles was nicht rosa ist anzuklicken und was auch immer und dann kommt halt am Schluss dabei heraus, dass du dich in der Beweisnot findest, als Kunde dem Anbieter zu überlegen, dass du das tatsächlich nur alleine benutzt hast oder so. Das denke ich das durchaus schon teilweise etwas kritisch an. Viele Songs sind geschrieben und dieser ist einer.
Ja, das war eine tolle Installation. Ach, mir fällt da gerade was ein. Wir haben übrigens für die ganzen Hörer, die jetzt im Internet versuchen zuzuhören, die beschweren sich nämlich immer, dass der Server nicht erreichbar ist. Also wir haben jetzt armdicke Leitungen gelegt und streamen gerade in Stereo. Das ist sozusagen Pilotversuch.
Es funktioniert auch.
Ich wollte es nur noch mal sagen, falls jetzt gerade einer im Auto unterwegs ist und gleich außerhalb des Sendegebiets Internet hat.
Leider streamt er spritzend nur mit viel Audio. Aber wie sieht das eigentlich mit unserem MP3-Server aus?
Ja, das ist heute des Projektes gestartet in der Realisierung. Um 21 Uhr mehr oder weniger. Na gut, es war 19 Uhr und jetzt hat das Clubmitglied jetzt aufgegeben, was dazu eigentlich bestimmt war. Echt? Und da wir jetzt hier lokale Probleme haben, gibt es erstmal kein MP3. Beim nächsten Mal planen wir dann auch, MP3-Versorgung machen zu können.
Glücklicherweise streamen wir ja noch in RealAudio.
Kleiner Tiefschlag. Wir sind heute ein bisschen ungünstig mit unserer Installation. Wir waren jetzt hier auch schon ganz, finde ich, und sind hier mit unserem ganzen Funk-Ethernet-Equipment angelaufen. Aber leider haben wir irgendwie wacke Kontakte, insbesondere in den Stromnamen.
Aber hey, es sieht sexy aus, also muss man mal sagen. Danke schön. Keine Ursache. Aber man sieht ja keine.
Ja, es steht ja keiner an, man kann es sehen, aber es ist leider nur dieses Oller an.
Also bitte, ich mache mal dein Mikrofon aus, mal gucken. Ach ja.
Tim, du brauchst gar kein Netz.
Hacker-Bashing-Man, ich brauche auch kein Netz.
Ich wollte hier ein WLAN machen.
Ja, okay, dann können wir das ja lassen, ich mache das hier gar nicht.
Also ich kann berichten, dass ich hier irgendwie schon ganz freudestrahlt und über meinem Laptop durch die Gegend gelaufen bin. Ich hatte dann auch Netz, weil da steckt links so eine kleine Kase drin, mit einem roten Kringel drauf und die macht halt Funknetz. Und das ist auch eine ganz tolle Sache. Aber da wollen wir ja eigentlich erst nachher zu kommen.
Eigentlich wollten wir das erst nachher.
Eigentlich wollen wir dann nachher erst zu kommen.
Ja dann machen wir jetzt noch ein bisschen Musik und dann machen wir das Info und danach kommen wir dann dazu. Da wollen wir doch mal, Falk. Falk, wo ist das Info? Da ist das Info. 22.30.
Der kubanische Flüchtlingsjunge Iljan González darf wieder in seine Heimat zurückkehren. Der Oberste Gerichtshof der USA lehnte einen Eilantrag von Iljans Verwandten aus Miami ab, mit dem sie die Rückkehr des sechsjährigen Jungen weiter verhindern wollten. Maßnahmen. Bund und Länder wollen mit einem Zucht- und Einfuhrverbot sowie schärferen Strafen die Gefahr durch Kampfhunde eindämmen. Brandenburg plant die strengen bayerischen Bestimmungen für die Hundehalter zu übernehmen. In Berlin soll ein Maulkorb und Leinenzwang für Kampfhunde eingeführt werden. Anhörung. Der Sonderermittler der Bundesregierung Hirsch hat das Fehlen von Akten und Computerdaten der Kohl-Regierung bestätigt. Morgen soll Altkanzler Kohl vom Spenden-Untersuchungsausschuss zu den verschwundenen Akten befragt werden. Fahndung. Bei einer Großrazie gegen internationale Verbrecherbanden sind heute in mehreren europäischen Ländern Wohnungen und Firmen durchsucht worden. In Deutschland konzentrierte sich der Polizeieinsatz auf Bayern, Sachsen und Hessen. Den Tätern werden Geldwäschebetrug und Steuerhinterziehung vorgeworfen. Verschärfung. Brandenburgs Justizminister Schelter will härter gegen Raser und betrunkener Autofahrer vorgehen. So wolle man die Bundesratsinitiative Sachsens unterstützen, die für Jugendliche unter 25 Jahren ein striktes Alkoholverbot am Steuer vorsehe, sagte der CDU-Minister.
Wette.
Nachts wolke ich mit einzelnen Schauern um 9 Grad, morgen stark bewölkt und etwas Regen, 15 bis 18 Grad.
Verkehr?
Verkehr.
A12 spree auch in Richtung Bundesgrenze zwischen Mühlrose und Frankfurt oder West. LKW-Rückstau im Grenzverkehr auf der rechten Fahrspur. Vorsicht bei der Annäherung.
Kurzen Show mit Falk Zielke, 22.32 Uhr, vielen Dank.
Kurken, Kurken, Grün. Gibt's nicht mehr. Das Endspiel der Euro 2000 auf Großbildleinwand im Columbia Fritz. Und nach dem Fußballspiel des Jahres, der Sportglumus. Mit MC Lücke, Oliver Welke und Lu Richter. Und dem großen EM-Rückblick live. Drei Wochen in drei Stunden wie live. Seid doch einfach dabei, am Radio oder selber. Sonntag, 2. Juli ab 20 Uhr im Columbia Fritz.
Chaosradio 51, wir wollten noch ein bisschen auf Flatrates rumhopsen.
Genau, Maulkorb und Linenzwang hab ich da gerade gehört. Echt? Da sollte man auch für die Marketingabteilung von den Internet-Anbietern irgendwie mal ausgeben.
Maulkorb und Linenzwang, wo beißen die?
Naja, die reden auf jeden Fall eine Menge dummes Zeug.
Ja, das mach ich aber auch.
Das ist schon gut, weil man sich von Zeit zu Zeit einfach mal einen kräftigen Ruck nach hinten hauen könnte.
Na, wie auch immer.
Wir waren bei Berlikon. Nein, Hans und ich waren da gerade.
Das ist natürlich auch eine attraktive Sache, weil bei diesen besonderen Telefonanbietern ist es ja so, dass Ortsgespräche kostenlos sind. Aber du hast doch jede Menge freie Minuten dann nach außerhalb des Landes. Das ist halt wieder nicht Festpreis, mit Berlikon wird es halt relativ einfach möglich, entweder zum Nachbarn direkt durchzukonnecten, also wenn man irgendwie MP3s von irgendjemanden anders saugen möchte, dann kann man da einfach mit geringer Latenz direkt anrufen. Das ist das eine, was schön ist. Das führt dann auch in Richtung Nachbarschaftsnetze, wobei man vielleicht auch noch mal ein bisschen was zu sagen. Denk ganz unüberricht.
Aber denk ganz unüberricht.
Ja, nein, das ist absolut.
Das fällt dem nicht weg, schön.
Ja, das ist halt 70 Jahre Terror durch die rechte verwertende Industrie.
Ich wäre auch froh, wenn es weg wäre. Aber es ist ungefähr so, als würde es den Grundbesitz abschaffen wollen.
Das glaubst du doch nicht.
Nein, nein, nein.
Da glaube ich wirklich ernsthaft dran.
Das ist vorbei.
Lineare Datenströme kann man nicht mehr mit irgendwelchen Copyrights belegen. Das geht einfach nicht.
Ja, das stimmt allerdings wieder.
Und die Durchsetzung von dieser Gesetzgebung, das ist einfach ein Krampf. Ja, das ist richtig.
Aber das heißt ja nicht, dass es aufgehoben wird. Es wird eben, also wie umgehend.
Nein, alle umgehend. Deswegen ist dieses Recht de facto eben nicht mehr vorhanden. Also jedenfalls nicht in den... Gut, aber das war nicht...
Nein, ich bin beim Team.
Ja, mit den Internetproviden. Es gibt halt auch im Berlikom-Netz auch Internetproviden, die man dann auch kostenlos erreichen kann. Kostenlos, also ohne Minutengebühr. Und da kann man teilweise eben direkt seine Gigabytes kaufen. Und da ist es dann auch relativ problemlos möglich, eine feste IP-Adresse zu bekommen oder eben ein richtiges Internet zu bekommen. Eben nicht... Eben nur feste IP-Adressen zu bekommen, also richtiges Internet.
Also eigentlich ist es die seriöseste Variante. Das einzige Problem ist, dass es sozusagen noch ein Maximum von 128 Kilobit hat. Das ist natürlich eigentlich schon mal gar nicht so schlecht. Aber man will ja eigentlich auch noch mehr.
Dann will man aber auch zwei Anschlüsse, weil sonst kann man nicht mehr telefonieren.
Na aber hast du kein Handy?
In meiner moderne Router können einfach den Kanal, wenn du deinen Telefon abhielst, dann bauen die den zweiten Kanal ab und dann kannst du telefonieren. Und wenn du den aufgelegt hast, dann bauen die wieder auf und das ist alles prima, weil der D-Kanal ja immer auf ist und der Signal ist einfach, hey, ich möchte da jetzt durchkommen.
Erklär das mal meinem Vater.
Boxen, fertig.
Ja, meine Trend geht irgendwie, meine Telefonieren kann man irgendwie mit seinem Handy.
So.
Da kann man jetzt auch Pizza bestellen.
Noch nicht teuer, aber eigentlich ist das, was man will. Also Telefonieren ist dieses kleine Gerät, was man irgendwo in der Tasche hat. Und nicht irgendwie so ein klogiges, ekliges, riechendes Plastikteil mit einer Strippe, was einen zwingt irgendwie in dem Raum zu bleiben, wo es angefangen hat zu klingeln. Bisschen daneben, aber...
Ja, ich war jetzt noch einer der schönen Zugangstechniken zum Internet. DSL ist ja auch eine ganz attraktive Sache.
Genau, die Telekommunikationsgesellschaften haben darüber nachgedacht, wie sie ihre Kupferkabel, die sie nun schon geschenkt bekommen haben, noch monotonistischer auswerten können. Und dann haben sie sich irgendwie DSL-Technologie einfallen lassen, was eigentlich gar keine schlechte Sache ist. Was sind, kennst du die Specks, mit der TDSL läuft?
768 Downstream, ja.
Und ab 400 Schnee.
128 oder?
Nein, 700, irgendwas.
Echt?
Aber ich weiß es auch nicht genau.
Das ist, also TDSL, dieses Produkt TDSL, das hat halt die Eigenschaft, dass es asymmetrisch ist, also es ist eigentlich ADSL-basiert. Und ADSL heißt asymmetrische digitale Subscriberlines, Subscriberline-Anstossleitung zum Kunden. Das ist halt so, dass diese Technik eben asymmetrisch ist. Der Upstream, also das, was der User zum Netz sendet, wird mit kleinerer Bandbreite geschickt als der Downstream. Das hat dann immer den Geruch des Unlauteren, weil dann die Gemeinde immer schreit, oh, das ist ja wie BTX und wie Fernsehen. Aber naja, man muss sich halt irgendwie auch vergegenwärtigen, dass 384 Kilobit oder auch selbst nur 192 Kilobit, die man bei dem Standardanschluss hat, dass das auch relativ viel ist. Also man kriegt sein Bild da schon in endlicher Zeit reingeschoben. Insofern ist das auch alles nicht so schlimm.
Genau, aber was dann sehr viel eklige, also eigentlich ist das keine schlechte Idee, weil man sozusagen die zwei Kupferaden, die irgendwie zu einem kommen, sehr Highspeed-mäßig nutzen kann. Nur, dass sie dann natürlich wieder noch ein Layer Scheiße obendrauf gelegt haben, der heißt PPPoE, das ist sozusagen PPP over Ethernet.
Da muss man jetzt aber dazu sagen, dass das nur Scheiße ist, wenn man einen Apple-Computer benutzt. Alle lachen da drüber.
Nein, das ist nicht wahr, ich bin ja auf was anderes hinaus. Ich bin echt darauf hinaus, dass Mac OS immer noch keine PPPoE-Implementierung im Betriebssystem hat. Das ist natürlich auch beachtenswürdig.
Aber auch der Rest von Mac OS ist auf dieser Ebene sozusagen weitgehend verachtenswürdig.
Von daher spielt das keine große Rolle.
Aber was halt blöde ist, dass sie DSL auf Zeit basiert verkaufen. Sie tun so, als wäre das eine Telefonleitung, über die man viele Daten schicken kann. Tatsächlich ist es aber ein direkter digitaler Connect direkt auf ihre IP-Infrastruktur, wo sie die Mono-Pakete vorbeigehen. Da sind DSL parallel auch noch zwei ISDN-Kanälen. Die macht sozusagen ISDN auch noch mit. Aber das benutzt man auch ganz normal wie ISDN. Das heißt, da hat man sozusagen seinen Zeitslog, den man benutzt. Das ist sozusagen auch angemessen. Aber der Rest ist halt digitale Daten. Das heißt, da kommen Pakete oder nicht. Und da gibt es nicht eine Verbindung, die geöffnet wird, außer die Verbindung, die sowieso schon da ist, nämlich die von meiner Anschlussbox durch die Kabel zur Telekom Hauptvermittlungsstelle. Aber nein, jetzt machen sie halt noch einen PPP da drüber, wie im normalen Modem. Das heißt, man muss diese Verbindung öffnen. Dabei ist die die ganze Zeit schon offen. Ach echt? Die liegt da. Da ist Ethernet, da kann man ein Paket hinschicken, mir geht das rüber. Alles gar kein Thema. Aber nein, da muss noch mal PPP drüber, damit man auch noch eine schwierige Konfiguration hat. Und vor allem, dass man eben für diese schon geöffnete Leitung, für das virtuelle Nacht, wie die eröffnen, auch noch zeitbasiert Geld bezahlt.
Haben die eigentlich noch die Einwahlstrafe dabei? Oder geht das jetzt?
Welche Einwahlstrafe?
Du wusstest ja, früher mussten sie sogar bei DSL, aber gerade, dass das ganz neu war, da hatten sie vor, pro Connect sechs Pfennige nochmal zu kassieren.
Keine Ahnung.
Was waren so die ersten Pressemitteilungen, die dazu rausgegeben hatten?
Dann war die Connect wahrscheinlich so schnell, dass alle ansonsten 100 Mal pro Minute auflegen und wieder neu anrufen.
Aber lass uns doch auch mal über Funknetz reden.
Das ist ein Spielverwerber.
Irgendwie gibt es jetzt das Tolle, was es in dem neu gibt. Wir sind ja diese Gadget-freundlichen Computer-Freaks. Und irgendjemand schleppte bei uns neulich diese Funkkarten an. Diese Funkkarten sind PC-Cards, also diese Karten, die man in die gängigen Notebooks und Laptops reinstecken kann. Und so eine Funkkarte sieht so aus wie eine normale Ethernet-Karte oder Bullion-Karte, was man so kennt, mit so einem kleinen Klötzchen dran. So ein kleinen Klötzchen, ungefähr so groß wie eine halbe Schreikerschachtel. Und diese steckt man in seinen Computer rein. Und dann hat man plötzlich Netz. Das ist das ganze...
Na ja, halt.
Ja, also ich meine, jetzt kommt natürlich auch das Betriebssystem an. Bei meinem Betriebssystem, das Privacy, da war das so, der rein gesteckt hat und dann lief das. Ich weiß nicht, wie auf dem Macintosh... Du kannst den Macintosh besser nicht einstellen. Das ist noch zu sagen. Auf dem Gerät war es so. Auf jeden Fall ist das ganz toll. Weil es ist nicht nur so, dass man dann, also wenn man so eine Gegenstelle hat, eine Base Station, eine sogenannte, oder einen anderen Computer, der auch so eine Karte drin zu stecken hat, dass man dann Netz hat, und zwar Ethernet, so schnell wie man also normalerweise mit den Kabeln auch ist, sondern die haben auch irgendwie ein Loch, und da kann man eine Abdeckung rauspupeln, die dann wieder rein geht. Die geht ganz einfach wieder rein. Und da guckt dann ein goldener Stecker ein, ein goldener, kleiner Stecker. Und wenn man diesen goldenen, kleinen Stecker eine Antenne anschließt, dann kann man damit nicht nur irgendwie 40 Meter, 50 oder 60 Meter, was man normalerweise ohne Antenne machen kann, überwinden, sondern auch 100 Meter, einen Kilometer oder zwei Kilometer. Und das funktioniert tatsächlich. Das funktioniert so gut, dass man einfach nur sich irgendwo hinstellt und in die Richtung seiner Antenne hält, wo man glaubt, dass der andere das Gleiche macht. Und dann hat man 300 Kilobyte pro Sekunde quer durch die Stadt.
Das ist einfach super. Kann ich das auch benutzen? Also wenn ich mir jetzt so ein Ding kaufe, kann ich mich dann irgendwo in Berlin hinstellen und Internet machen? Es ist von Orten berichtet worden, wo man nur im Sushi-Laden zu sitzen braucht.
Und dann hat man auf einmal ein Netz und sieht, da ist sogar ein Internet dran.
So ist es sozusagen dieser Traum der 80er Jahre. Doch endlich mal auch in der Strassenbahn Ethernet machen zu können mit so einem Gerät, was auf den Knien ruht. Das ist jetzt sozusagen The Future is Now.
Gibt es denn da echte Anbieter, zu denen ich sage, ich möchte jetzt gerne mit dir und Funk Internet machen? Oder ist das Zukunftsmusik?
Ja, das Problem ist dabei, dass zunächst mal ist es so, dass jeder sich diese Karten kaufen kann und auch betreiben kann. Die sind also anmeldefrei und auch gebührenfrei. Dieses Frequenzband, auf dem das funktioniert, ist ein freigegebenes Frequenzband für kommerzielle Nutzung auch freigegeben. 2, 4 Gigahertz, 23 Zentimeter. Aber das Problem ist, dass man nicht normalerweise Kommunikationsdienstleistungen für jemand anders anbieten kann. Das heißt, auf Funkbasis. Das heißt, ich kann nicht einfach jetzt hergehen und meine Base Station dahinstellen und sagen, lieber Holger, du kannst jetzt bei mir Internet machen. Genau, ich kann das zwar machen, aber das ist illegal, weil dafür brauche ich eine Lizenz, wenn ich das für dritte mache. Und dazu kommt dann erschwerend, dass diese Lizenz nicht etwa nach dem tatsächlich anzubieten, also wenn ich jetzt sage, ich möchte hier meine kleine Base Station, maximal 40 User, dann ist die Lizenz nicht davon abhängig, was ich damit bedienen kann, sondern davon abhängig, wen ich theoretisch erreichen könnte.
Technische Reichweite.
Ja, und das ist dann auch noch so definiert, dass es da so Verwaltungsbezirke gibt, die man kaufen kann. Das heißt, eine Lizenz kostet so in Millionenbereich. Also diese ganzen UMTS-Lizenz, worüber man ja jetzt viel gehört hat, da geht es um große Beträge und da glaubt der Staat jetzt, diese Lizenzen für großes Geld an die große Industrie verkaufen zu können. Das ist natürlich Spaß. Das ist eigentlich Spaß.
An welche Orte muss ich mich begeben? Ach, hier können wir gleich trojeren, wenn die Mikros aus sind. Wir denken mal, das Männchen will ja nie wieder reiten. Chaosradio 51 und wir reden über, was reden wir? Zerfunknetzung, darf ich das mal so platt ausdrücken? Zerfunknetzung, wie geht das technisch?
Ja, so Netz sieht eigentlich so aus, man hat diese Karte, diese 802.11b Karten, entweder Lucent Wavelan, die Karten heißen jetzt Orinoco, oder es gibt noch ein paar andere Anbieter, es gibt NWN, es gibt noch so Wavelan, oder so gibt es noch so eine Karte, egal, du kaufst so eine 802.11 Netzkarte.
Die kostet mich wie viel?
Die sind hier in Deutschland glaube ich 400 Mark, in Amerika 180 Dollar, wenn du gut bestellst. Mit diesen Karten kann man dann schon untereinander vernetzen. Also wenn ich drei Computer habe und alle drei so eine Karte, dann können wir untereinander schon reden. Das heißt dann Ad-hoc-Networking, da muss man dann anklicken im Treiber, oder irgendwie, oder was hast du da merkt?
Das geht auch bei drei, du musst einen schon zu einer Base Station machen.
Nein, du kannst Computer Peer-to-Peer ohne Base Station, ohne etwas, Peer-to-Peer betreiben. Das hat aber Nachteile. Das große Nachteil ist, dass der Performance sucks. Und das kommt dadurch, dass sobald mehrere Stations in diesem Netz einander nicht mehr hören, es ist nicht wie Ethernet. Bei Kabel, Ethernet hören alle einander. Das heißt, es gibt nur Collisions, Probleme, wenn zwei genau gleichzeitig anfangen zu reden. Dann gehen die beiden mal zurück, oh, das war falsch. Und dann kommt einer, die warten dann random Zeit, und dann kommt einer zurück und fertig. Das ist bei Wired Ethernet, da hören alle einander. Bei Wireless Ethernet hast du so etwas, das heißt, das Hidden Note oder Hidden Station Problem. Das heißt, A, B und C reden miteinander. A und C reden beide zu B. Aber A hört C nicht. A ist zu weit von C. Das heißt also, jedes Mal, wenn C etwas Großes zu A sagt, ein großes Paket oder etwas, was weiß ich was, JPEGs oder was denn auch, dann redet A da durch. Und dadurch geht die Performance wirklich runter. Das ist wirklich schlecht.
Wie weit? Also 300K in der Sekunde kann ich machen damit, habe ich gesagt.
Das kannst du nur von einer bis der andere, wenn da nur zwei Stations im Netz sind.
Wenn ich einen dritten dazu hänge, kann man das irgendwie so...
Dann geht das schon richtig runter. Wenn du mit drei Leuten oder vier Leute richtig benutzt, dann geht das mal zehnfach runter.
Ja, wir sehen das auch im Moment. Das ist halt so, wir haben halt so eine Konfiguration, wo wir über einmal 1, 5 Kilometer gehen und einmal über 500 Meter oder so. Und da sehen sich die beiden, zwei sehen sich halt nicht. Die punkten alle zu einer Mittelstation. Und wenn da nur einer Download macht, ist alles prima. So 100, 200K pro Sekunde jederzeit möglich. Aber sobald der andere versucht, da drauf zu gehen, bricht das so richtig ein. Also es wird so richtig langsam.
Ja, dann gibt es sowas, das heißt in diesem Protokoll heißt das ein Access Point. Und ein Access Point hat auch so eine Karte und hat die Rolle, das ein bisschen richtig zu verteilen. Das macht, was früher im Netze so Token Ring hieß, so erst du mal, dann du, dann du, verteilt so ein bisschen, dass alle reden und erzählt doch alle anderen, dass gerade Hans mal redet. Also halt mal alle Klappe, weil Hans redet jetzt. Das heißt ein Access Point. Und diese Access Points gibt es in Hardware, also als Gerät, aber gibt es für den Macintosh zumindest auch als Software. Kannst du einfach einen Macintosh als Software Base Station konfigurieren. Für Base Stations, mit einem Base Station im Netz, kannst du also mit 10, 20 Leute problemlos arbeiten und dann bleibt der Bandbreite einigermaßen.
Und die Base Station kann jeder Rechner sein, der in dem Netz hängt oder muss es jeder sein? Jeder, der 20 Rechner, den ich da habe?
Für die Mac gibt es im Moment ein Software Base Station. Weil es ist wirklich auch auf dem Ether-Niveau eine andere Rolle. Es gibt zwei Niveaus. Es gibt die Waveline-Niveau. Da gibt es so eine Rolle. Und dann gibt es die IP-Niveau da drüber. Du kannst zwar Peer-to-Peer-Networking machen und dann hast du auch eine Gateway zum Internet zum Beispiel. Aber das ist dann noch nicht automatisch auch die Waveline Access Point. Wenn das auf dem Waveline-Niveau alle noch gleich sind, dann ist die Performance scheiße. Und deswegen will man dann so ein Access Point im Netz haben. Es gibt also Hardware Access Points und für den Mac auch ein Software. Und die Hardware Access Points, davon gibt es eine, die sehr billig ist, viel, viel billiger als alle anderen, das ist die Apple Airport-PayStation. Das sind die Waveline-Produkte von Apple. Und du hast eine Airport-Karte, die in all diesen neuen Apple-Computer reinpasst. Das ist eine Waveline-Karte ohne Antenne, weil die Antenne schon in diesem Computer drin ist. Kostet nur 100 Dollar statt 180. Kannst du einbauen in einen neuen Apple-Computer. Und für diese Line of Products haben die dann auch so eine PayStation. Und das ist alles sehr billig, weil Apple mehr iBooks und mehr Computer dadurch verkauft.
Kann ich da so ein altes Powerbook einbauen, das 1400er?
Da musst du die ganze Waveline-Karte kaufen.
Aber wie schon erwähnt, für die alten Powerbooks sehe ich das mit Treiber ein bisschen haarig. Normalerweise laufen die Waveline-Karten halt auch mit der Airports-Software, aber die installiert sich eigentlich nur auf den G3s. Und ich habe es auf dem älteren PowerPC-Modell zum Laufen bekommen. Es könnte sein, dass es bei dir auch geht.
Aber dann müsste ich schon basteln können, ne?
Ja, nee, du musst nur irgendwie, weil es schon die bunten Icons an der richtigen Stelle stehen müssen.
Ja gut, das ist bei Apple immer schön.
Nicht so wirklich schwierig. Du kannst ja auch mal ausprobieren.
Wenn man so ein Netz hat, das ist eigentlich, was man alle so braucht für ein Heimnetz, dann hat man so ein Netz im Haus aufgebaut und die Reichweite, wenn man die Base Station gut platziert, ist die Reichweite so im Haus zwei Wände. Sagen wir mal, so zwei Wände und eine Tür. Mein vier. Wenn du eine große Wohnung hast, dann musst du die Base Station schon richtig gut platzieren, sonst hast du irgendwo kein Netz. Du kannst auch mehrere Base Stations an dem gleichen Ethernet anschließen und dann kannst du Roaming machen. Das heißt, du kannst vom einen Bereich der eine Base Station im anderen laufen und dann geht das Netz einfach weiter.
Ich muss den Effekt nochmal beschreiben. Ich bin in diesem Business tätig, bin Software-Entwickler und da komme ich ab und zu mal zu irgendwelchen Firmen. Und es ist immer der gleiche Effekt. Du hast irgendwie ein Notebook, du hast diese Karte da drin zu stecken und dann kommen sie alle an.
Wo geht es kommen?
Hier ist es mal.
Das habe ich doch eben auch.
Ja, genau.
Stellt dieses komische Apple-UFO irgendwo hin, das aussieht wie bei L'Oréal, der Familienbenutzer seiner Zeit. Und das erste, was ich gesagt habe war, geil. Kann das Internet mit Funk?
Die Leute fangen dann sofort an mit der Karte drin, sofort aus dem Raum zu rennen, gucken, wie weit geht das, habe ich hier draußen im Flur auf der Toilette.
Internet.
Das ist wirklich sehr schön.
Ja, tolles neues Spielzeug. Und vor allem macht es halt richtig Spaß, wenn man damit irgendwie nicht nur seine Wohnung versorgt oder seine Firma, sondern wenn man das Ganze dazu benutzt, auch einfach diese ganzen nervigen TK-Firmen, über die wir ja schon geredet haben, einfach mal links liegen zu lassen und sich in seiner Nachbarschaft mit in der Nähe wohnenden Leuten zu vernetzen. Also es gibt nicht wenig Leute.
Ja, allein bei mir im Haus wüsste ich drei, mit denen ich das sofort veranstalten könnte.
Genau, einerseits natürlich Leute, die in deinem Haus wohnen, und dann aber auch eben von Straße zu Straße. Wie oft hatte man das Problem, dass man gerne mal ein Kabel über die Straße geworfen hat, aber dann kommt man nicht so richtig ans Dach und irgendwie was rüber schmeißt. Man weiß ja auch nicht so richtig, so und so braucht man jetzt eigentlich nur noch so ein Ding irgendwie oben aufs Dach zu stellen.
Ihr könnt euch dann einfach, ich sag mal, die URL durch. Das ist ja heutzutage die moderne URL durchsagen.
Sagen wir mal. Also es gibt da zum Beispiel so ein Projekt von einigen Leuten, die da jetzt befleißigt sind, irgendwie sowas hier in Berlin zu installieren und sozusagen schon eine erste Netzinfrastruktur aufzubauen. Und es gibt da einen Web-Server unter darbo.dabo.citywave.net. Da könnt ihr mal ein bisschen klicken. Da gibt es schicke Bilder von Antennen auf Dächern und Wave-Ladenkarten und viele Kabel. Und es sieht alles sehr nördig aus.
Das ist verpasst.
Und da kann man halt sehen, dass es alles affordable Technologie ist. Also mit so einem Aufwand von irgendwie 2000 Mark kann man zwei Orte, die ziemlich weit auseinander sind, also auch so drei Kilometer, sehr performant mit den erwähnten 200 Kilowatt pro Sekunde miteinander verbinden.
Zum Quaken oder so reicht das locker.
Die Frage ist dann auch, dürft ihr das oder macht ihr das einfach? Also ist das jetzt Piratenradio oder?
Wenn das irgendwie mein persönliches Netz ist, was ich privat mache, das Digitale ist so gelassen.
Aber in dem Moment, das habe ich eben richtig verstanden, in dem Moment, wo du jetzt sagen willst, die kommen vorbei, du darfst hier Internet machen, gib mir ein Fünfer dafür, in dem Moment wird es ein Knast sein.
Du darfst halt ohne Lizenz nicht Kommunikationsdienstleistungen für die Leute anbieten. Solange das innerhalb einer Firma, eines Vereins ist, oder wenn du mit mir, dann ist das einfach unsere Sache. Dafür ist das auch Frage.
Ist so ein tolles Gesetz wie in den 80er Jahren, dass man irgendwie keine Modems an unsere Telefonen anschließen durfte, weil das ist ja Bebe und das darf nur die Telekom. Das war halt auch ein sehr modernes, zukunftsgewandtes Gesetz. Und von denen gibt es halt immer noch einige, wie zum Beispiel dieses. Die haben einfach eine definierte Halbwertszeit. Man kann also einfach sehr vorausschauend mit diesen Gesetzen zukunftskompatibel umgehen und dann werden wir auch alle Spaß damit haben.
Diese große grüne Antenne gefällt mir irgendwie sehr gut.
Die ist toll. Die ist auch 1, 60 m lang. Ich meine, die hat natürlich, eigentlich benutzt man so eine Antenne, um von der Erde auf den Sativiten raufzukommen. Das ist nämlich auch das gleiche Sequenzband, 23 cm. Aber die funktionieren halt auch in der Stadt ganz prima. Die sind deswegen toll, weil die eine sehr kleine Keule haben. Das heißt, die sind sehr gerichtet und du versäust damit nicht so einen riesigen, machst dann nicht so einen riesigen Strahlenwind auf. Denn natürlich, wenn jeder sich solche Karten aufs Dach stellt und riesige Antennen in alle Richtungen leuchtet. Dann geht insgesamt natürlich die Bandklasse, die es auf der Suche steht, ganz klar runter.
Es ist gut, mal zu gucken, wenn man richtig mit Richtfunk anfängt, ob da vielleicht irgendwelche Militaranlagen oder Flughafen so in Linie liegen. Das wäre nicht schlecht, das mal zu wissen.
Dann wird eben Tegel endlich dichtgemacht. Ja, das hat ja auch was für mich.
Mir ist gerade eingefallen... Die Boeing, die hol ich mir.
Ich hab ja ein stündliches Signal zu geben, das mach ich gerade mal. Entschuldigt mich kurz?
Ja, genau.
Am heutigen Mittwoch das Chaosradio 51 und wir unterhalten uns gerade und später auch mit euch über Verfunknetzungen und das gibt's in Berlin schon.
Angriffen kann man sich das unter dabo.citywave.net Du hast den Jingle um 23.05 und 42 Sekunden gespielt.
Das ist richtig.
Das fand ich ziemlich bemerkenswert.
Warum fandest du das bemerkenswert?
Das kann ich dir nicht erklären, wenn du das nicht weißt.
23 Sekunden.
Also dabo.citywave.net steht übrigens auch hinter einem Waveline-Link. Wenn die Performance jetzt irgendwie runtergeht, dann erlebt ihr, was passiert, wenn man im Ad-hoc-Modus ist, mit diesen Waveline-Karten und da keine Koordinierung stattfindet. Dann geht eben die Performance.
Mir fällt gerade noch ein, dass ihr mit diesem dabo und mit diesem Rosenthaler Platzgeschichte auch noch ein anderes Problem habt. Das ist SOL, Speed of Light. Wenn du alle diese Notes auf unterschiedliche Punkte multipoint machst, und alle diese Notes sind unterschiedlich weit weg, dann hast du auch da noch Zeitverschiebungsprobleme. Also auch mit einem Axis-Point, der Zeitflots macht, bin ich mir noch nicht sicher, ob das alles dann so performant funktioniert, als ob man alle im gleichen Raum ist.
Also das werden wir ausprobieren, würde ich sagen.
Aber nur so eine Gedanke.
Ich habe ein Lichtgeschwindigkeitsproblem.
Du musst uns eine neue Welt suchen, eine schnellere Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Genau.
Hat das nicht jetzt einer geschafft, irgendwie Lichtgeschwindigkeit zu...
Das wäre zu überholen?
Ja, zu überholen.
Du meinst Tunnelling?
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe es irgendwo, irgendwo in einer Nachricht gelesen.
Tunneln von Licht. Aber es...
Wie geht das?
Ja, komplizierte, mystische Voodoo-Dinge, die ich hier habe.
Das ist auch über Wave-Fans, Broadcast-Network aufgebaut.
Es gibt schon.
Tja, ich meine, diese Funkgeschichte, das ist ja auch alles nicht ohne Vorgeschichte. Früher gab es irgendwie so diese fleißigen CB-Funker, die irgendwie schon angefangen haben, Minimalspannbreiten-Pakete über Radio zu senden, Packet Radio.
Das Schlimme war ja nicht, dass das CBler waren, weil die CBler haben ja immerhin noch gewisse Spontanität. Sondern Packet Radio kam halt von den Amateurfunkern. Funkkontakt wird ja auf einer Karte dokumentiert. Und auch jedes Paket, was dann erfolgreich zurückkam, wurde dann auch gefeiert, einzeln gefeiert. Das war halt alles noch sehr langsam. Das als Vorläufer zu bezeichnen, ist halt doch ein bisschen gewagt.
Es gibt auch einen.
Okay, dann fällt mir noch ein anderer Vorläufer ein.
Der geht eher in diese Kategorie.
Da gibt es doch dieses RFC, was die Übertragung von einem Pipaketen mit Brieftauchen durchgeschnitten wird.
Entschuldigung.
Rauchzeichen. Na ja, da wurde es in den 90er Jahren ein bisschen moderner.
Dann kam diese Deck-Technologie.
Das ist das, was man heute gemeinhin für schnurlose Telefone verwendet, die digital verschlüsselt zu ihrer Anschlussstation die Sprache übertragen.
Oder eben auch für IP-Pakete.
Was hat ihr gemacht?
Wir haben uns einfach gedacht, warum Daten schleppen auf festen Mediumen. Zu einer Stelle, zu einer anderen. Und haben dann einfach von Siemens diese M101-Data-Teile gekauft. Die sind eben dafür da, dass man in einem Zimmer seinen Rechner hat. Das Ding an die serielle Schnittstelle packt. Und zwei Räume weiter sein Modem. Und dann kann man halt da irgendwie sein Modem mit ansprechen. Und ist halt ein langes serielles Kabel. Per Funk.
Mit Luft da drin. Mit Luft da drin.
Genau. Und warum haben wir uns gesagt, die Dinger nicht einfach missbrauchen und irgendwie Point-to-Point-Verbindungen darüber laufen lassen. Und das haben wir dann einfach gekauft und probiert. Und hat prima geklappt. Einfach auf jeder Seite ein Rechner. Und Funken dran. Und dann kann man da locker irgendwie 300 Meter bei Sichtverbindungen verbinden.
Habt ihr da drauf aus, viele?
Es kommt aufs Wetter an. Also Packet-Loss ist keiner drüber, wenn die Serie-Schnittstelle irgendwie ein bisschen darmarschig ist. Aber wenn jetzt zum Beispiel ziemlich warm ist, dann gehen dann die Funken auch gerne mal aus, weil die mögen es nicht so. Aber richtig cool ist dann halt bei Regen. Und komischerweise bei Nacht. Ja, bei Regen und bei Nacht ist es schneller. Wir können uns das auch nicht. Also es hat gar nicht mit der klaren Luft zu tun, aber bei Nacht klarer Luft.
Es ist einfach dunkel.
Na ja, bei Nacht ist es deswegen schneller, weil da keiner Decktelefone benutzt. Meinst du, das ist so extrem wirklich? Na ja, der Rauschlevel ist niedriger.
Aber Sonnenlicht hat Hacker-Aktivitäten immer schon eingeschrieben.
Das ist eine gute Erklärung.
Ich benutze nachts sogar manchmal ein Deckt-Telefon.
Ja, aber echt.
Ich finde es sehr schäbig von den Zuhörern, dass die jetzt hier die blöden Podscannen auf der Arm da, wo ich hoffe, eher hat seine Security da im Griff.
Genau, hört doch mal mit Podscannen rein auf, die Leute wollen sich die Bilder angucken.
Apropos Deckt-Telefon, mir fällt da gerade an, die Telekom, die hat ein schnurloses ESDN-Telefon, falsch ausgepreist, da steht nämlich unten nicht dabei, dass man das nur für den kleineren Preis kriegt, wenn man auch gleichzeitig einen ESDN-Anschluss nimmt.
Was war das jetzt? Diese Datei nicht löschen, ja nein?
Genau, diese Datei nicht löschen. Das klingt mir gerade zum Thema schnurloses Telefon ein. Vielleicht ist das eine Information, die ganz hübsch ist. Es gibt da so ein schnurloses Telefon bei der Telekom, im Laden zu kaufen, das kostet irgendwie 500 Mark, ESDN. Und da steht ja dann normalerweise dran, kostet 250, aber nur, wenn ein Neuanschluss legen lässt. Die waren jetzt aber zu blöd, auf das Preisschild drauf zu schreiben, kostet nur 250, wenn ein Neuanschluss legen lässt. Da steht jetzt drauf, kostet 250 Mark. Und die verkaufen es dir für den Preis.
Morgen sind die alle weg.
Wo ist der Laden?
Überall. Das ist wirklich, das ist offensichtlich eine Serie.
Du löst jetzt die DOS-Attacke aus.
Ich hab ja schon eins.
Nein, das ist wirklich praktisch.
Wie heißt denn dieses Telefon?
Easy 520 oder so ähnlich, also ein ganz einfaches. Ja, aber hey, das ist schon urlos und kann ISDN.
Cool, ich weiß, was ich morgen mache.
Also bei mir im T-Punk hab ich das eben gemacht und die haben dann auch direkt das Schild aus der Auslage genommen.
Oh Gott, gib her.
Und dann hab ich's in Charlottenburg in der Post, hab ich's auch noch mal gesehen.
Das ist überall.
Ja, da bin ich ja mal gespannt. Ich glaube, das werd ich morgen mal...
Nee, da ist keiner.
Niemand hat sich da eingeloggt.
Geht doch mal zum Rosenthaler Platz.
Genau, das Geld, das wir jetzt haben.
Wir haben gerade kostenloses Internet.
Der erste Hacker, der jetzt irgendwie am Rosenthaler Platz Netz kriegt, der darf sich was wünschen. Ich weiß nicht, aber...
Ich kriege eine Mate.
Bitte, lass uns was einfallen.
Wir schweißen ab und ich war es schuld.
Macht doch nichts.
Wo waren wir denn?
Wir waren... Na ja, wir reden ja gerade über das, was wir reden wollen. Wir haben quasi diese tolle Deck-Anbindung. Also es gibt halt schon immer irgendwelche Funk.
Genau, da wollte ich ja nochmal die Carls Haus da irgendwie grüßen. Die haben ja das Ganze zur gleichen Zeit irgendwie betrieben wie wir. Die sind aber da irgendwie ein paar Subnetze weiter, weil da irgendwie auch mehr Leute wohnen, die das gerne machen.
Also die haben damit jetzt ein richtiges Netz aufgebaut und untereinander Routing gemacht.
Na ja, das haben wir ja auch. Aber die haben halt mehr Nodes.
Ja.
Die haben halt irgendwie... Mit Internet. Ja, mit Internet.
Das heißt, dass die Leute darüber dann über Internet angeschlossen sind.
Die haben da bei uns ja auch.
Ja, das meine ich jetzt.
Aber es steht ja in den AGBs, dass wir das nicht dürfen.
Ihr seid da nicht in der Bucht.
Nein, sind wir nicht. Wir haben kein Internet, deswegen sind wir hier. Na jedenfalls haben die auch ganz viele Rechner und ganz viele Nodes und die haben da auch nicht so viel Stahlbeton. Und deswegen ist das bei denen auch nicht ganz so kritisch mit der Sichtverbindung, was da bei uns nicht so gegeben ist.
Das ist der Hype.
Das ist der Hype. Als ich gelesen habe, na Mobilnetzen. Wie ist das in Japan? 70% der Leute, die da Netz machen, gehen über ihr Handy.
Was, GSM?
Nee, die haben da PCN.
Was kann das? Also wie schnell?
Das kann mehr.
Wie viel könnt das?
Weiß das jemand? Mehr, also auf jeden Fall mehr als GSM.
Eigentlich kann alles mehr als GSM.
Nein, die Amis können überhaupt nicht.
Ja gut, aber das sind ja auch die Amis. Die wollen ja auch nicht.
Ja, die lieben analoge Systeme. Ich weiß auch nicht, die haben also von einem immer die NTSC-Version. Ja, naja gut, aber auch hier wird alles irgendwie ein bisschen besser. So diese GSM, also GSM Standard ist halt ein 9600-Bit-Pro-Sekunde-Kanal und jetzt wird das irgendwie alles gerade massiv aufgerüstet. Mit diesem HS, also es gibt da ein HS-CSD-Modus, mit dem kann man dann irgendwie 14.4 machen. Und dann gibt es noch dieses HS-CSD, damit kann man dann mehrere Kanäle bis zu wie viel?
Ach, ich glaube 40K oder so kann das, ne?
Bündeln, dann kommt man, ne, dann kommt es auf Modem-Geschwindigkeit, 56K.
Reicht so, ja das ist wunderbar. Für die Strassenbahn und so.
Ist toll für E-Mail und so.
Scheiße, Station verpasst.
Aber es ist eigentlich nicht das, was man haben will. Vor allem das Problem ist, man muss dann halt Kanäle aufbauen. Es ist immer noch diese alte Telefonsicht der Dinge mit irgendwie Channels aufbauen, obwohl es eigentlich auf diesem Planeten mittlerweile nur noch Pakete gibt. Und der nächste Step heißt GPRS. Das ist dann Global Packet Radio System heißt das, oder? Wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall ist das dann vielleicht irgendwie mit ohne Verbindung aufbauen, sondern einfach digitales Paket rausschicken, also richtig schon Internetverhalten mit normalen GSM innerhalb dieser erlaubten oder möglichen Bandbreiten. Und der nächste Schritt ist diese, wo sie jetzt gerade alle sinnlos viel Geld für die Lizenzen ausgeben, ist halt UMTS, der Universal Mobile Telefon Standard. Da fällt man ja fast um, wenn man das hört.
Zwei MBit oder was auch immer.
Genau, und da gibt es halt irgendwie zwei MBit ins Portablegerät. Das ist glaube ich so in etwa, das wäre so was cool.
Das ist toll.
Also ich meine, die Weltbahn ist eigentlich noch teurer, weil damit gibt es ja fast bis zu 10 MBit.
Und ohne Telefongesellschaft. Wir brauchen keine blöde Callcenter-basierte, blödsinnige Warteschleife mehr, sondern wir stellen den Bauch ab.
Ich mach nochmal ein bisschen. So, jetzt kauf ich mir so ein Kärtchen und stell mich in Berlin an diesen Platz.
Die Freiheit nimmst du dir.
Die Freiheit nimm ich mir, genau. Und ähm...
Schnapp die Waveladenkarte.
Du solltest nicht Hansens Waveladenkarte anfassen.
Das war nicht meine Waveladenkarte, sondern mein Fuß.
Ich hab die Fuß nie angefasst, ich hab drauf gedreht.
Seine Waveladenkarte. Nein, noch besser, ich bastel mir jetzt zuhause mit meinem Nachbarn Andreas, bastel ich mir jetzt ein kleines Netzwerk und mach da Internet mit denen. Und jetzt kommen Kreti und Pleti bei mir im Haus vorbeigefahren und klinken sich damit ein, also ist es sicher?
Man kann es sicher machen. Es gibt Encryption, die kann man anmachen, dann hat man 40 Bit Encryption, das ist zwar scheiße, aber es ist mindestens was, das heißt, dass man zumindest ein bisschen Mühe sich machen muss, um bei dir im Netz zu kommen. Aber keiner macht das an. Alle wollen so eine Airport Base Station haben, und alle wollen, dass das gleich funktioniert. Und die kaufen also diese Base Stations, nicht nur die Apple Base Stations, sondern all diese Access Points. Und das geht in diesen Büros und Abteilungen von großen Großfirmen, kommt das einfach rein, keiner weiß, wo die Dinger stehen, keiner weiß. In 80er und frühe 90er Jahren gab es diesen Mythos der Desktop Modem. Die Leute, die dann so ein Terminal in ihrem Arbeitszimmer hatten, und die dann gerne mal zu Hause arbeiten, und die machen dann so ein eigenes Modem und knüpfen da selber an, an ihrem Bürotelefon, damit die dann selber von zu Hause mal anrufen können.
Wollen wir mal telefonieren? Frage an die Hörer?
Fragen der Hörer. Ach so, ja genau.
Wir würden gerne von Leuten hören, die entweder mit Waveline oder anderen Datenfunkgeschichten hier konkret aktiv sind, und da vielleicht interessantes Wissen.
Oder Leute, die in der Fernsehturm arbeiten.
Oder Leute, die zu dem, was wir hier diskutieren, konkrete Fragen haben.
0331 für Podstar, 7097, 110.
Ja, die ist geschaltet. Dann warten wir doch mal ab, ob der eine oder andere anruft. Da klingelt es.
Wenn er eins als Null ruft, dann hört mal jemand.
Komische Vorweise.
Registrieren Sie sich hier 0493... Die Verschlüsselung ist RC4. Was ist davon zu halten?
Wird im Moment nicht mehr für 100 Prozent sicher gehalten. Und wenn man die 40-Bit-Version nimmt, dann ist das eben nicht wirklich sicher. Aber es ist zumindest... Es hält alles ab, die sich nicht wirklich Mühe geben. Bei dir, genau bei dir. Also ich würde das große Firmen nicht raten, sich mit 40-Bit RC4 zu verlassen. Aber zumindest für zu Hause reicht das dann völlig aus, damit es keinen Stass und Ärger gibt.
Also ich könnte mir so einen Teil kaufen. Und fahre jetzt einfach mal in Berlin rum und gucke, ob sich das nicht irgendwo...
Es ist wirklich wie mit Kreditkarten, weil die Orinoco gibt es in einer Silver-Version, die macht halt 40-Bit, und dann gibt es noch die Gold-Card, die macht 128-Bit. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie dann nochmal eine Platinum-Card rausbringen irgendwann.
Geht schon.
Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Hier ist das Chaosradio. Hallo hier.
Ich wollte eigentlich mal fragen, wie ist eigentlich die Uhr?
Habt ihr das aufgesetzt gekriegt mit dem Icecast?
Nee, mp3 ist nicht. Irgendwie haben wir zu spät mit angefangen und gibt's da nicht. Ich hab's dir auch als Mail geschrieben.
Hab ich nicht gekriegt, interessanterweise.
Ja, das ist Internet voll.
Das Internet ist kaputt.
Ansonsten hab ich Dabo gerade gebooted. Irgendwie keine Ahnung, was da jetzt mit war.
Wahrscheinlich irgendwelche bösen Attacken.
Ich hab noch nicht genau nachgeguckt, bin auch gerade erst nach Hause gekommen.
Verstehe, naja, da sind aber fleißig die Requestes drauf am Laufen. Also dabo.citywave.net Okay.
Das war's schon?
Ja, nö, ich mein irgendwie, wir können doch mal die wohl von dem Real Audio Stream nennen.
www.fritz.de und da direkt vorne ist...
www.test-underscore-neu.ram Irgendwie so was.
Das ist ja keine Seite, wo der Real Audio Stream nicht verlinkt ist. Deswegen ist das auch Kammern hinzu, weil die Leute das im Büro anklicken und dann weggeben.
Und zwar wollte ich sagen, wir setzen das bei uns an der Uni ein.
Welche? Welche Uni?
Welche Uni? In WIthlan? WIthlan, genau, wir haben da zwei Karten. Eine ist im Rechner drin, als Skateboard praktisch, und die andere haben wir so mobil. Und das geht also über mehrere Wände, nicht nur über zwei Wände. Wir können damit aus dem Keller bis zur Wiese und den Hörsaal und so. Das ist richtig herrlich, also.
Ja, aber das kommt immer auf die Wände an, also, wie gesagt.
Das ist ein neues Institut, also dieses Informatikinstitut da bei uns. Und da können wir echt weit damit hinkommen. Nur eben das Problem ist die Strombesorgung der Laptops da, weil die eben nicht so lange halten.
Welches Gebäude ist das?
Medienzip-Gebäude.
Die Adresse? Adresse ist kacke.
GPS-Koordinaten. Die stehen im Netz drin, glaube ich, irgendwo.
Ein Problem an diesem Ad-Hoc-Modus, den ihr da wahrscheinlich auch benutzt, ist, dass man auch die Stromsparfunktion nicht aktivieren kann, weil diese Karten haben ja eigentlich einen Stromsparmodus.
Das machen wir ja, bloß die Laptops halten ja nur zwei Stunden mit den ganzen Dingen, also das ist das Problem, die Strombesorgung überhaupt.
Und was macht das in der Uni für einen Sinn mit zwei Karten?
Na, das ist ja erstmal in der Maupar, also wir sind da am Panelein, dass wir eine Antenne auf den Dach kriegen und es geht schon alles, aber...
Mit welchen Typen?
Ja, ich bin gleich notiert. Ja hallo, ich habe mal eine Frage und zwar, vorhin habt ihr noch gesagt, dass man da hinten was rauspulen kann und da noch eine Antenne reinstecken kann. Und dass es auf einen Kilometer dann ungefähr geht. Klappt das denn auch, wenn man nur das 2.1. machen möchte?
Datenaustausch.
Das geht ja auch durch so eine kurze Wand und wieder eine Wand rein.
Na ja, normalerweise schon. Wände sind halt dann kein Problem, wenn es nur zwei sind und sie nicht zu dick sind. Es gibt dicke Wände, durch die man überhaupt gar nicht durchkommt. Aber es gibt auch dicke Wände, bei denen es geht. Und wir haben einfach die Erfahrung gemacht, dass das meiste einfach geht. Also man probiert es aus und es funktioniert. Man stellt sich aufs Dach, hält es in die Richtung und man hat einen Connect. Und also naja, ich kann nur sagen, ausprobieren und die Chancen sind gut.
Also wir haben bei uns ausprobiert, wir haben ein Fenster, also ein Fenster haben wir so oder so immer dazwischen. Da kann man dann zwar noch die Performance-Balkon-Tür aufmachen, um noch mehr Leistung zu bekommen. Da kann man also tunen, aber auf der anderen Seite ist immer das Fenster offen. Und wenn man da das Fenster zumacht, dann ist braun. Dann ist echt runter.
Und die Antenne, ist das denn ein Kabel?
Ja, du musst dir sogar das Pigtail kaufen. Das ist praktisch Adapter von dem Stecker, der in der Karte drin ist.
Schweinigwänchen.
Ja, Schweinigwänchen für 98 Mark oder so. Und da hinten ist dann ein Männer-Antennensstecker drin, wo man ordentlich Antennen ranmachen kann.
Das ist nicht schlecht da, weil wir hatten ja mal wie... Bei CB-Funk war das ja auch mal, dass man Daten an sich übertragen konnte.
Ja, aber das ist halt eine ganz andere Leistungsklasse, weil es ist wirklich schnell.
Also das ist klick und da.
Also meistens.
Also die Nutraten, was du rauskriegst, was du oben auf deinem IP-Stack siehst, das ist so 2, 4, 6 Megabits, sowas in der Größenordnung.
Das sind ungefähr 46 Pizzas pro Minute.
Tschüss, tschau. Ich unterbreche mal kurz. Frankreich, Portugal 2 zu 1, die Froschfresser haben gewonnen. Das Leben ist kein Wunschkonzert. Hier ist Chaosradio. Niemand.
Mal sehen.
Mach mal dein Radio leise, bitte.
Ihr seid on air, ja, okay. Ich hab nämlich ne Frage zu nem bestimmten Banking-System, und zwar HWCI. Wie sicher ist das?
Gar nicht.
Okay.
Gar nicht, und es ist auch nicht unser Thema. Unser Thema ist Verfunknetzung.
Genau. Es gibt Internet, erkläre deiner Bank, dass es Internet gibt, und sie sollen es benutzen. Da braucht man kein HWCI.
Dann wird alles sicher mit Java und Beacritics und... Ja, wir haben leider keine Antwort drauf.
Wir sind hier nicht die Bankexperten gerade.
Das ist nicht die Support-Hotline.
Doch, das ist schon die Support-Hotline.
Naja, aber nicht da. Naja, genau. Wir wollen jetzt nicht über Banken reden.
Genau, lass uns über das Funknetzung reden. Wo kriegst du eine Karte? Überall?
Und diesen Piktails?
Weil, unter Ihres Vertrauens würde ich sagen.
Die Karten und Access Points kaufst du überall. Und die Piktails und Antennen in spezialisierten Radio-Omateur-Laden.
Gut sortiert verachtet. Ja, also da ist auch wirklich empfehlt, wer sich damit beschäftigen möchte, nicht unbedingt die Antennen und dieses Zeug bei Lucent zu kaufen. Also bei den Herstellern dieser Karten, weil die einfach mal richtige Apothekenpreise haben und man da besser beraten ist, wenn man zu einem Funk-Händler geht, zu einem üblichen.
Mach Werbung, wenn du für einen Werbung machen willst.
Ich weiß nicht, ich hab einfach das Telefonbuch, das Branchenbuch geguckt unter Funk und fand da einen Händler. Ich weiß den Namen wirklich nicht.
Ich dachte, du hättest einen guten auf der Pfanne.
Nee, die Antennen gibt es von VIMO, aber die bestellen die da auch nur. Also www.vimo.com, da gibt es lange 23 cm Antennen, alle ganz toll. Von Rundstrahlern, Primostrahlern, Weinstrahlern, Konrad-Katalog.
Das steht auch. Europameisterschaft, Frankreich hat zum zweiten Mal nach 1984 das Endspiel einer Europameisterschaft erreicht. Die Franzosen bezwangen die Portugiesen mit 2 zu 1 in der Verlängerung. Entscheidung, der kubanische Flüchtlingsjunge Elian ist auf dem Weg in die Heimat. Er bestieg am Abend mit seinem Vater in Washington eine Chartermaschine. Der oberste Gerichtshof der USA hatte zuvor einen Eilandtag von Elians Verwandten aus Miami abgelehnt, mit dem sie die Rückkehr des 6-jährigen Jungen verhindern wollten. Maßnahmen, Bund und Länder wollen mit einem Zucht- und Einfuhrverbot sowie schärferen Strafen die Gefahr durch Kampfhunde eindämmen. Brandenburg plant, die strengen bayerischen Bestimmungen für Hundehalter zu übernehmen. In Berlin soll ein Maulkorb und Leinenzwang für Kampfhunde eingeführt werden. Anhörung, der Sonderermittler der Bundesregierung Hirsch hat das Fehlen von Akten und Computerdaten der Kohlregierung bestätigt. Morgen soll Altkanzler Kohl vom Spenden-Untersuchungsausschuss zu den verschwundenen Akten befragt werden. Verschärfung. Brandenburgs Justizminister Schelter will härter gegen Raser und betrunkener Autofahrer vorgehen. So wolle man die Bundesratsinitiative Sachsens unterstützen, die für Jugendliche unter 25 Jahren ein striktes Alkoholverbot am Steuer vor siehe, sagte der CDU-Minister.
Wette!
Nachts beeinfällt Schauer um 9 Grad, morgen stark bewölkt und etwas Regen, 15 bis 18 Grad.
Vielen Dank, ein kurzes Info mit Falk Zielke, das ganze um 23 Uhr und 32 Minuten. Ja und ihr solltet jetzt......so blöd sein...
.8 Jahre Blackboard Jungle, mit Reggae, Hip-Hop, Drum'n'Bass, Two-Step, Big Beat, mit über 30 DJs auf die Floor.
Kuma-Sattic, Minsky, High, Smallface, Buzz, Die Obi-Wan, Feed, der Lächeln des Schamanen, das Concrete Jungle und das Supersonic Soundsystem und einfach viel zu viel, um sich alle aufzuzählen.
8 Jahre Blackboard Jungle, mit Barbecue und Kalpirinias am Strand. Samstag, 1.
Juli, ab 15 Uhr. Die Insel, Berlin-Triptow. Und den Blackboard Jungle hört ihr ansonsten immer Freitag um 20 Uhr. Auf geht's! Ich bin schon.
Ich bin schon mal da.
Du bist echt übel.
Chaosradio 51, 20 von 12. Wir reden über Funknetze und was man damit machen kann und vor allen Dingen, wie man damit machen kann. Schlechtes Deutsch kann ich gut. Du hast mir ein Tape gegeben, da ist nichts drauf, Tim.
Das stimmt nicht.
Das stimmt. Ich lüge fast nie.
Da ist was drauf.
Ich bin verblüfft.
So viel dazu.
Wo waren wir denn überhaupt stehen geblieben?
Die Läste-Ecke ist jetzt eröffnet.
Du hattest ein Problem mit deinem Free-Mail-Anbieter.
Oh, du hast eine Schiemsäue. Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Da irgendwie mein Mail-Host leider noch keinen Web-Mail-Service hatte und ich irgendwie in die weite Welt hinaus musste, und du weißt ja, wie das ist, wenn man irgendwie Nerd ist und keine Mail hat.
Geht nicht.
Also, so musst du mal sowas nehmen. Dann habe ich so einen großen, dreibuchstabigen, deutschen Web-Mail-Anbieter genommen.
So ähnlich.
Und alles wäre ganz toll gewesen. Also, wahrscheinlich wäre alles sehr richtig toll gewesen. Das hat irgendwie funktioniert. Da kamen E-Mails rein. Man konnte sie lesen, man konnte sogar welche schreiben. Und der hat sie auch nicht gelöscht, weil ich halt noch sechs Mark im Monat extra bezahlt habe, damit ich sozusagen so...
Profi-Account.
Naja, ich brauchte ja auch HTTPS-Zugang für irgendwie kritische Orte, die ich zu betreten vorhatte. Und naja, vor allem hatte ich keinen Bock, dass ich mir meine Mail nach 30 Tagen wischen. Naja, wie gesagt, alles hätte gut werden können. Nur nach einer zweiwöchigen Exilpause.
Das ist jetzt für den Profi-Account her.
Ey, tolles Chaos-Klavier.
Jaja, das war für den Profi-Account. Und naja, dann habe ich irgendwie so ein bisschen mit meinem Namen rumgespielt. Also man kann dann so in den Optionen seinen Namen ändern. Weil, wenn man das ändern kann, warum soll man das da nicht auch ändern? Ich ändere meinen Namen immer nach meiner aktuellen Befindlichkeit.
Ich hatte keine Erklärung für den Systembetreiber.
Keine Erklärung, warum oder so.
Na ja, dann irgendwann, damit man sozusagen der Urlaub in seiner Endphase auch vollkommen zerstört, irgendwie alle wichtigen E-Mails irgendwie für die Rückreiseplanung und so weiter, alles weg. Und dann musste ich mir für den Leuten anhören lassen, ich hätte die AGB-Richtlinien bezüglich der Anonymitätsrichtlinien verletzt, weil ich ja irgendwie meinen Namen geändert hätte. Ich meine, ich frage mich, warum sie einem überhaupt erlauben, den Namen zu ändern, wenn das irgendwie automatisch zu einer Verletzung von irgendwelchen AGBs führt.
Welcher Anbieter war das? Ja, drei Buchstabenorganisationen.
Nachdem ich ihnen dann irgendwie eine Kopie meines Passes per Post geschickt habe, waren sie dann auch so freundlich, dann irgendwann diesen Account wieder freizuschalten, aber selbstverständlich haben sie mit der Sperrung des Accounts auch...
Hast du die 6-malige?
Sei froh, dass sie nicht die Original deiner Reisepasse wollten.
Ja, aber warum hast du denn nicht einen ISP, der sowas wettbasiertes anbietet?
Hab ich jetzt. Ja, nachher ist man schon, aber vorher gab es das nicht, und so ist das halt immer. Und irgendwie, ich bin jetzt ein bisschen erzürnt, und jetzt ist vielleicht die Blässe am Maul-Geschichte vielleicht mal...
Also ich habe noch nicht irgendwie, was mich auch wieder dazu bewogen hat, das direkt zu meinem Nachbarn funken toll zu finden war, ich habe neulich einen Trace gemacht von mir zu Hause, zu einer Maschine, die auch in Berlin steht, und die ging viermal über Frankfurt. Viermal. Und zwischendurch war sie in Stockholm, in Brüssel, in Amsterdam, in Düsseldorf, in Drill, so mit fünfmal New York City, und dann wieder zurück. Oh, ich bin ja gar nicht für hier. Also da habe ich mir gedacht, was soll der Mist eigentlich? Selbst wenn das mit dem Delay alles sich noch im Rahmen gehalten hat, und da nur irgendwie 350 Millisekunden dabei rausgekommen sind, ist das doch einwandt, wenn die Entfernung irgendwie eigentlich zwei Millisekunden rechtfertigen würde. Insofern, also vernetzt euch direkt.
Geografisch basiert das Routing. Das ist halt genau das, was diese Waveladengeschichte von Dach zu Dach automatisch mit sich bringt. Also dann ist halt irgendwie der Weg auch nicht so weit, wenn der Weg nicht so weit ist.
Hier ruft gerade einer an. Hier ist das Chaosradio. Du hast dich willkommen im Radio, Hoppe. Das soll doch so ein Poser klingen.
Aber der Zylophon hat ja gar nicht vorher dip, dip gemacht.
Wo war er dran, mein Herr?
Nee, der wurde unverschält. Jetzt nehmen wir mal noch einen anderen an. Hier ist das Chaosradio, Fritz.
Wir sind da am Bein. Und?
Tschüss. Chaosradio.
Hallo, Herr Hans-Peter. Und ich wollte dich beschwerden, mal direkt da über die Funkdienste. Gut. Aus mit den Rechnungen. So, äh, die, wo da, wenn man da verarscht wird, als D2 und so, ne bloß.
Ja, ne, darum geht's ja jetzt hier gar nicht, ne. Also es geht hier darum, dass wir Internet-Verfunknetzen wollen. Also Internet-Drahtlos sozusagen.
Genau, wir reden hier nämlich gerade über...
Aber ich finde es nicht so gut, was, was die Leute da bringen. Wenn jetzt, weil ich glaube nicht auch, dass da euch, eure Hörer da auch zu hören. Und mit den Funknetzen, das läuft so. Die werden da beschissen, mit ihrer Monomal-Stadtgut haben.
Nee, nee, das geht ja.
Du hast da glaube ich was mit verstanden. Hans-Peter, findest du nicht auch, dass in Chile grundsätzlich mehr Kartoffelsuppe ausgegeben werden sollte als Taxis in New York fahren?
Ja, und dann mit den SMS und so. Und die wurden auch an...
Hans-Peter, wir reden hier darüber, dass wir das, was die Leute so normalerweise mit einem Kabel zu Hause machen, nämlich Internet, dass wir das drahtlos und mitnehmbar machen wollen und möglichst kostenfrei für alle anderen auch. Das hat mit Telefonen jetzt erstmal gar nichts zu tun.
Telefon ist aus.
Da rufst du jetzt leider Gottes in der falschen Sendung an und es warten noch ganz viele Leute in der Leitung. Und genau darum werde ich dich jetzt leider rauslaufen. Bestimmt, Hans-Peter. Tschüss.
Tschüss.
Hier ist das Chaosradio.
Hallo, ich wollte nur noch sagen, auch bei dem großen Abend wieder mit den drei Buchstaben mit dem E-Mail-Account, wenn man den normalen nimmt, dann wurde ich nach einem halben Jahr, weil ich mein Modem kaputt hatte, wollte ich mich einlocken, dann hieß es, der Account wurde leider gelöscht, da sich die Benutzung nicht innerhalb von einem Vierteljahr mehr gemacht hat.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, super.
Und dann wollte ich mich neu anmelden. Ja, leider wird er nicht.
Fünftigen ASP, ja.
Aber es gibt einen richtig guten.
Ich will ja keine Schleichwerbung machen, aber der hat wirklich alles. Und bei dem habe ich noch keine Probleme gehabt. Der hat auch drei Buchstaben, fängt aber mit W an.
Wie sind denn die anderen beiden Buchstaben?
B und E, aber das war jetzt die falsche Reihenfolge. Damit nicht direkt jeder drauf kommt.
Die haben dann bestimmt Frames und Java. Die hatten doch letztens irgendeine Serverprobleme.
Nein, das geht ohne JavaScript. Die hatten Serverprobleme. Das geht ohne Frames, ohne JavaScript.
Ohne Cookies?
Ohne Cookies, ganz genau.
Echt?
Ja, ich habe also Java, JavaScript, Cookies, alles aus und es funktioniert trotzdem.
Da gibt es ja so grausame Systeme. Ja, wo die speicherne, ohne zu fragen, irgendwelche Cookies mit Zufaller-Login-Informationen werden dann irgendwo in Mexiko...
Das kannst du auch, was ich auch vergleichsweise vorbildlich finde, bei Web.de ist, dass die auch deinen Account wirklich erst dann freischalten. Du gibst denen die Adresse und die schicken dir dann einen Code, also irgendeinen kleinen Schlüssel auf die Zahl.
Die E-Mails sind aber nicht wirklich unter Kontrolle. Die E-Mails können dir die Adressen nix schicken, da kriegst du ganz komische Bounces zurück.
Aber trotzdem andere Sache, zum Beispiel bei GMX oder so, wenn ich mal so sage, habe ich dann so ein schönes Formular, was haben sie denn so für Hobbys, was würden sie denn so in ihrer Freizeit machen?
Ja, und was sie auch noch alle von einem wollen, wissen wollen, sie sollen.
Genau, da befrage ich mich doch, wollen die das nicht, nur um meine E-Mails zu lesen und vielleicht am Werbezeug immer eine Adresse machen?
Haben sie eine Freundin?
Wir rufen Speicher und auch einen Service.
Ich finde aber trotzdem einen richtigen ISP, wo du auch vielleicht mal anrufen kannst und sagst, ey, ich habe hier ein Problem, der dir dann hilft, das finde ich irgendwie schon ganz cool. Die Grundgebühr und so.
Bei web.de rufst du an und die helfen dir dann?
Ja, bei denen kannst du auch anrufen und die helfen. Echt?
Ich wage das zu bezweifeln.
Also wir könnten gleich mal das Experimentchen machen.
Ich glaube, die haben richtig eine Nummer, die haben richtig einen Service.
Okay, super.
Ich glaube, wir schweifen vom Thema ab.
Ich habe mich jetzt auch wieder beruhigt, aber es ist einfach beim Thorn entlassen. Also wirklich Mails löschen gehört wirklich zu dem, ich finde das ist einfach...
Wenn das einer macht, dann ich selbst.
Bei mir.
Radio hier, wer da? Keiner. Dann nehmen wir den. Hi, Peter.
Und zwar habe ich mal eine Frage, ihr habt euch ja vorhin noch über Flatrate unterhalten, ne? Darf ich da drüber auch mal eine Frage stellen? Aber hallo. Und zwar steht ja in den AGBs drin, dass ich die nur von einem Computer aus benutzen darf. Und wenn ich jetzt aber ein Netz zu Hause habe, und ich will, dass alle so halt eben ins Internet gehen können. Und ich hab das jetzt bei mir zu Hause so gemacht, so mit Windows-Internet-Verbindungsfreigabe, ja, dass das halt eben alles über einen Rechner geht. Dann sind das ja eigentlich auch mehrere Rechner, aber eigentlich ja doch auch wieder nur eine. Also zählt das dann auch?
Ja, zählt als nicht.
Ist doch eigentlich völlig wurscht, ob nur jemand irgendwie einen Rechner 8 Kilobyte pro Sekunde braucht oder ob da irgendwie drei Rechner 8 Kilobyte pro Sekunde brauchen. Das ist völlig egal eigentlich. Wenn sie es zum Beispiel nach Traffic abrechnen würden, hätten sie da irgendwie überhaupt keine Probleme mit.
Ja, deswegen, weil das ist ja auch bloß eh nicht. Weil jetzt auch hier der Inne-Anbieter da irgendwie die ganzen Leute da, seine ganzen User verklagt hat.
Ja, das war, weil sie angeblich das irgendwie geschäftlich sind. Ja, da muss man ein bisschen aufpassen. Also nicht von der Firma irgendwie.
Das gilt dann aber als Mist, auch wenn ich das so mache.
Eigentlich schon, und dann unter Umständen kommen sie ihm vorbei und sagen, du hast benutzt und dann rechnen sie dir irgendwie 3, 60 Mark pro Stunde, die du benutzt hast.
Einen verlimitierten Anwalt.
Vielen Dank für diesen Hinweis. Danke für deinen Anruf, wir machen weiter. Hier ist das Chaosradio, könnten wir mal über Verfunknetzung reden?
Eigentlich schon.
Aber eigentlich auch nicht.
Und warum nicht?
Na, warum nicht?
Wie wäre es, wenn du dein Radio leise machst?
Portugal hat verloren und deswegen, ich war schon immer für Frankreich.
Natürlich.
Kann ja passieren.
Aber wir wollten eigentlich über Funknetz reden.
Ja, aber ich denke es nicht.
Vielen Dank, tschüss. Hier ist das Chaosradio.
Andi fehlt.
Hallo, ich wollte mal fragen, was ist jetzt ein Funknetz? Hallo, ich wollte mal fragen, ist ein Funknetz jetzt das da? Ich wollte da jetzt von euch wissen.
Da reden wir ja die ganze Zeit drüber.
Am besten die E-Mails, am besten Ampy-Dosen.
Du, E-Mail ist wirklich nicht unser Thema. Das war ein kleiner Exkurs des Kollegen Fritlav, der sich einfach nur über seinen Sprüh-E-Mail-Anbieter eschufieren wollte. Das hat er getan. Und darüber reden wir aber heute Abend leider Gottes nicht. Das tut mir leid. Wir versuchen nämlich im Chaosradio 51 über Verfunknetzung zu sprechen, über Netzwerk ohne Kabel.
Was man damit zum Beispiel so machen könnte, was die Leute für Ideen haben, ist das gar keine. Wir wollen das gar nicht haben.
Nein, wir rufen ja noch genug an, wir probieren das weiter aus.
investiert, hat irgendwelche Satelliten hochgeschickt, um weltweit ein, um... Tiledesic-Iridium-Netzwerk zu bilden, oder so ist das herausgebaut wie irgendwas hier verordnet?
Na, das ist Tiledesic, wo Gates beteiligt ist. Das gehört ihm glaube ich nicht alles, aber er ist da irgendwie mit drin beteiligt. Und das ist halt so ein System, wie... Also was so ähnlich funktioniert wie das von Iridium, wo das Iridium etwas hirnbeschädigt geplant wurde, sodass sie irgendwie mit super kleinen Bandbreiten und irgendwie teuren Geräten an Start gegangen sind. Und ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob die Baktele desig nächstes Jahr starten oder 2003 irgendwie coming up. Also das wird sozusagen noch ein Thema werden und die wollen dann halt über Seite die zwei Megabit anbieten, nächsten Jahren kräftig Konkurrenz bekommen. Weil die Abdeckung in den urbanen Zonen mit GSM-basierten oder UMTS-basierten Netzen ist einfach extrem hoch bzw. wird extrem hoch sein. Und ob das dann mithalten kann, wage ich doch stark. Also das ist auf jeden Fall ein interessantes Rennen, weil natürlich ein Device, wie ein Laptop, deutlich weniger Energie darauf verwenden muss, bis zum nächsten Häuserblock zu funken, wo dann irgendwie so eine Antenne auf dem Dach steht, als irgendwie so einen niedrig fliegenden Satelliten anzupeilen.
Wäre denn mit dem normalen, ich will jetzt nicht, wie der Kollege vorher hier auf diesen D1 sicherlich zurückkommen, aber wäre denn die Antennenauslastung möglich, oder müsste das auch...
Man dann eben das Internet bei diesen Funkdiensten anbieten, einkauft, D1, D2 und wie sie alle heißen, und wenn man halt Wavelarn macht, dann schafft man sich eben seine eigene Infrastruktur.
Die dann auch nicht bezahlt werden muss.
Und die unheimlich Spaß macht.
Ja, die cool ist, flexibler ist, irgendwie ist es halt Ethernet, also ist auch softwaremäßig alles gar kein Thema, auch mit den aktuellen Open Source.
Das erinnert mich irgendwie an diese Geschichte in Amerika, wenn du durch kleine Orte fährst, ist es jetzt so, dass du alle 5 km an anderen Radiosender hast. Muss man sich das denn so vorstellen, oder?
Was meinst du, ein anderes Internet alle 5 km?
Ja, noch besser immer dasselbe, an anderen 5 km.
Es hat sicher damit zu tun, in Amerika gibt es Low-Power-License. Das ist es genau auch.
Das ist sozusagen ein Erfolger, oder so etwas Vergleichbares, was sicherlich sich bilden wird, oder?
Ich meine, auf dem Internet selber bildet sich... Also einerseits, wenn du jetzt mit Radio kommst, ist es natürlich so, dass auf dem Netz, durch Streaming-Technologie, sich sozusagen ohnehin schon eine eigene Radioszene aufbaut, unabhängig davon, wie das Internet dich jetzt erreicht. Und mit Wave-Lan kannst du halt irgendwie auf eine relativ coole Art und Weise an Netz rankommen. Dass das letztlich bedeutet, dass du deinen coolen Piraten-Sender, der aus Feuerland irgendwie Daten streamt, irgendwie im Mont-Bizou-Park der Laptop im Rucksack mit Kopfhörer auf, irgendwie den Walkman langsam ersetzt. Ja, das ist so das, was jetzt ansteht. Du lachst, ich hab das schon gesehen.
Wann sieht man ein theoretisches Senden so was mögliches? Ja, bloß die Frage, wer macht mit?
Na, wir machen auf jeden Fall mit. Weiß nicht, wie es für dich ist.
Gibt es da schon Piratenradio aus Feuerland?
Noch nicht.
Wenn nicht, dann machen wir eins. Was hat ein Feuerland für eine Endung?
Danke für deinen Anruf.
Hier ist Chaosradio. Wir wollen über Funknetz reden.
Du auch?
Ja, hallo, hier ist Jens. Und zwar wollte ich mal fragen, wie das eigentlich mit der gesundheitlichen Sache aussieht und so weiter, wenn hier so viel in der Gegend rumt.
In einem Bettkasten unter mir, da schlafe ich so ziemlich eigentlich jede Nacht, wenn ich nicht zuhause bin.
Das sieht doch gut aus, der Junge.
Das sieht doch gut aus. Noch geht's.
Ich benutze das auch die ganze Tag und bin auch fiel ich nur mal.
Es wird eine Leistung von den Karten. Und das heißt, es wird da keine signifikante Energie ausgestrahlt, die irgendwie jetzt direkt durch Erwärmung oder so irgendwas bewirken könnte.
2, 4 Gigahertz ist nur die Resonanzfrequenz von Wasser. Und du hast eh kein Wasser in deinem Körper.
Ich meine, die ganze Geschichte ist halt doch eher esoterisch. Denn es wird zwar immer wieder gefragt und auch behauptet, dass es Elektro-Smoke gibt.
Und das kann man erst seitens Direct-Sequence-Spreads um diese Technologie, damit man dieses Rauschen von diesem erst benötigten Waageband noch frei. Und wenn man mit so einer Karte im PC nutzt, ist das kein Problem. Aber wenn man da mit einem 500 mW Booster auch noch in einen dicken, großen Yagi-Antenne reinschiebt, dann sollte man vielleicht nicht die ganze Tag davor stehen.
Kann ich jemand einen 2KW Mikrowellenherd umbauen?
Na kann man da nicht mit alten Mikrowellen irgendwie richtig hören?
Wenn du das Türkontakt...
Wollt ihr jetzt mit den Mikrowellen irgendwelche Flugzeuge abstürzen lassen oder so?
Das ist schon Planung, man.
Danke für deinen Anruf und wir sehen uns weiter.
Tschüss!
Und das Chaosradio Nummer 51 heute, wir wollen oder reden eigentlich schon die ganze Zeit darüber, Internet drahtlos zu machen und zwar so richtig, also nicht mit Handy, sondern mit Verfunknetzung und kleinen Karten, die man in die Computer reinsteckt und dann rein theoretisch an jedem Ort der Welt oder zumindest der Stadt, derzeit geht es nur am Rosenhahn am Platz, Internet machen kann und zwar in einer akzeptablen Geschwindigkeit. Habe ich das richtig wiedergegeben, meine Herren?
Akzeptabel ist fast schon untertrieben.
Ich würde sogar noch ein bisschen weitergehen, der Titel war ja Neue Bürgersteige im globalen Dorf. Da ist halt Waveline jetzt irgendwie das heißeste Thema gerade, weil das irgendwie ganz andere Vernetzungsstrukturen ermöglicht. Aber ich denke, dass sich auch wandelt, wie man sich anschließt. Also letzten Jahren war halt State of the Art, dass man irgendwie sein Modem im Computer hat und das wählt dann den Internet-Service-Provider an und dann surft man. Also so ein relativ steriler, gerade gerichteter Zugang. In unseren Kreisen ist es eigentlich sehr verbreitet, dass man irgendwie nicht einen Computer hat, sondern halt mehrere. Die Zahl bewegt sich da von, ich weiß nicht, 5 bis N. Man möchte die halt irgendwie alle betreiben. Das heißt, typischerweise kommt so ein alter PC mit ins Spiel, den man sich irgendwie aufrüstet. Dann tut es irgendwie ein alter 386er oder 486er auch ISDN-Karte rein, ein UNIX drauf, das UNIX der Wahl, welches das dann auch mal sein mag, und dann eine Ethernet-Karte rein und schon hat man eben sein eigenes lokales Ethernet-Netzwerk und dieser kleine alte Computer surft dann einem den Internetzugang. Wenn man irgendwie einen etwas moderneren PC nimmt, kann man halt diese Maschine zu seinem, das tun eben auch viele, irgendwie zu seinem Home-Server ausbauen, gerne irgendwie auch gleich noch ein Proxy zur Verfügung stellt, irgendwie einen lokalen Backup-Server hat.
Mail-Server.
Einen Mail-Server, dann fährt man vielleicht auch seine eigenen Domains. Also man wird sozusagen autonomer im eigenen Heim und alles das, was man heute noch irgendwo hosten lässt, möchte man ja eigentlich auch direkt von zu Hause machen können, dass man nicht mal erst irgendwo hinfahren muss, wenn die Maschinen mal abgestürzt sind, sondern dass man das eben da hat, wo man ist. Das ist ein Modell, das sich irgendwie gerade entwickelt. Damit kann man dann auch seine Webcam im Klo auf dem eigenen Webserver realisieren.
Der Kloserver.
Genau, der Kloserver. Ihr habt ja hier auch eine Webcam.
Nee, da habt ihr das Ethernet rausgezogen.
Ach so.
Das war wieder gut.
Da hast du dein Netz her.
Nö, irgendwie muss ich ja hier, weil diese Apple Hardware versagt wird.
Bevor das hier übernimmt, ich geh nochmal ins Telefon.
Hier ist das Chaosradio, hallo?
Ja.
Ist geil, ne?
Ja, ich sauer, man.
Schade, dass du nichts beizutragen hast. Hier ist das Chaosradio, hallo?
Ich hab mal eine Frage. Und mal geht es um die Internetanbindung über Satellit. Und zwar ist meine Frage, wie sich der Kostenrahmen da bewegt? Für zum Beispiel Gigabyte-Download im Monat, ob das günstiger wäre, DSL zu nehmen oder sich eben über die Schüssel da anzubinden?
Tja, das Allereinfachste ist, die Preise selbst zu vergleichen. Wir haben da jetzt auch nicht die Preislisten dran.
Für mich ist das ein bisschen undurchsichtig gestaltet. Das geht dann irgendwie, das geht zwar ab 20 Mark, gut Gebühr oder so. Und dann geht es je nach Download, staffelt sich das dann.
Du meinst jetzt dieses TLS Zeug, ne?
Ja, so eine richtige Obergrenze ist daraus nicht ersichtlich aus den ganzen Angeboten.
Das hat ja auch alles keine Obergrenze. Da zahlst du halt fürs Gigabyte so und so viel Mark. Und wenn irgendjemand dir dann Gigabyte einhilft, dann darfst du die bezahlen.
Aber ist das denn nun prinzipiell teurer noch, über Satellite zu empfangen, als über ISDN oder ISDN ist vielleicht ein bisschen langsam, aber ISL oder sowas?
Das Problem ist, dass bei diesen Satellitendienst, wo wir vor zwei Tagen darüber geredet haben, bezahlst du pro Minute und die Bandbreite ist nicht genial. Also du kriegst dann immer noch nur ISDN oder weniger Bandbreite und du bezahlst pro Zeit und nicht pro Bit.
Du musst ja auch immer noch einen Upstream offenhalten.
Und du musst Upstream immer noch über ISDN oder Telefon machen.
Und das wird auch zeitabgerechnet, oder?
Auch wenn du dann im Durchschnitt weniger als ISDN bekommst, dann kannst du besser irgendeine Flatrate-ISDN-Provider nehmen und fertig.
Eben T-Online, Flatrate, DSL-Ran.
Das sieht zwar aus, als ob es noch billiger wird in nächster Zeit, oder?
Teurer wird das bestimmt alles nicht. Also, ich meine, es kann ja auch kaum noch teurer werden. Preise hier in Deutschland für Internet sind einfach noch...
Total beschissen, genau.
Also, zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt irgendwie ein 24-Monats-Pertrag für den Flatrate, äh, Flatrate 64 qubit zu kaufen, ist nicht so schlau.
Was zahl ich denn in Holland zum Beispiel?
In Amsterdam gibt's für etwa 60, 70 Gulden, also 60 Mark, sagen wir mal, kriegste Kabel-Internet und dann hast du eigentlich immer wohl eine Megabit down und 2650 up, Flatrate.
Das wird wohl noch ein bisschen dauern mit dem Kabel, bis hier so alles versorgt ist, auf den Surfer und so.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es hier in Berlin aussieht, aber in Amsterdam ist jetzt alles versorgt. Da kriegst du für 60 Mark, hast du alles, was du haben willst, Flatrate.
Da fragt man sich ja dann, warum behaupten die in Deutschland immer, dass sie technische Probleme haben, wenn es andere können?
In Österreich soll das ja auch nicht schlecht sein.
In Österreich ist es grundsätzlich eher schlecht, oder?
Ich kann mir das nicht so recht vorstellen.
Also ich habe neulich bei so einer Podios-Diskussion diesen Kabelfritzen wieder mal zugehört von einer Kabelgesellschaft. Und wenn man sich das anhört, dann hat man stark den Eindruck, dass sie auch in zwei, drei Jahren noch nichts auf die Reihe bekommen werden. Also ich mache mir da nicht so viel Hoffnung. Ich denke, der Weg ist jetzt, dass Provider mit DSL an den Markt gehen und einfach gute Flatrate-Angebote machen. Das ist eigentlich das. Kabel, Fernsehen, dieses Netz, da wird jetzt irgendwie gesagt, was weiß ich, wie viele Jahre drüber geredet, dass sie das vielleicht endlich mal hinbekommen. Aber diese Leute reden einfach immer noch von interaktivem Fernsehen, haben einfach überhaupt nichts begriffen, wollen irgendwie TCP-IP in DVB-Rahmen übertragen und sind einfach total panne und daneben vergesst diese Leute einfach, bevor die mal was ordentliches anbieten können. Also außer Pilotversuchen ist da bisher noch nicht sehr viel passiert.
Ja, das dauert auch nur bis die ersten Kabelnetze für Städte hier von Großfirmen, von amerikanische Großfirmen gekauft werden, nur mit dem Ziel, da mal richtig Internet anzubieten.
Na ja, es geht jetzt gerade los. Ich meine überhaupt, dass dieses Jahr Flatrate so stark gekommen ist, dass es auf einmal irgendwie für 100 Mark ordentlich Internet gibt. Im Endeffekt, dass das selbe Programm hat irgendwie vor zwei Jahren. Da wollte die Telekom allein für die Einrichtung 700 Mark pro Seite einmalig haben. Also nur, dass sie sozusagen die erlauben, dass du Kunde werden darfst. So dafür, dass da irgendwie so ein heiliger, ich weiß nicht, die haben da glaube ich so eine Priesterkaste bei der Telekom, die gehen mit Weihrauch durch den Rechnerraum und besprenkeln deinen Telefonanschluss, damit er auch gut funktioniert. Und für diese Zeremonie müssen halt Gebühren an die Kirche abgefüllt werden, deswegen ist es zu teuer.
Dafür gibt es dann unten so ein Stempelchen noch drauf.
So ist das.
Genau. Danke für deinen Anruf.
Möchtest du uns was sagen oder fragen?
Heute nicht, nee.
Die Themen sind leider aus Tüberland.
Hier ist Chaosradio Fritz, hallo.
Ja, hallo. Ich hab mal eine Frage. Und zwar erst mal, ihr redet ja die ganze Zeit über Funk-Lans und so weiter. Da hat's mal eine Sache von Diamond.
Ach, die Home-Free-Teile.
Ja, die Home-Free-Teile. Ist das selbe Protokoll oder ist es irgendwie jetzt anders?
Nein, das ist irgendwie was ganz Proprietäres. Irgendwie hab ich den Eindruck. Und die sind doch nicht wirklich cool.
Also die haben im Prinzip eigene Kanäle gekachtet und dann darüber Netzwerke gemacht.
Ja, ich weiß jetzt aber nicht genau, wo die da ihre Frequenzen haben und wie die das genau machen, aber...
Diamond sind jetzt diese Grafikkarten?
Ja, Diamond, die haben ja inzwischen alles aufgekauft, was sonst noch so durch... Also sie kaufen gerne, ja. Wir müssen jetzt auch noch irgendwie Pappbecher bauen und genau.
Noch eine andere Frage jetzt. Die Waveline-Sache da. Ihr meint ungefähr, also der alte Weg war jetzt über einen ISP und dann anwählen mit einem Modem, tralala. Theoretisch bräuchte man dafür ja auch ein Modem und so weiter. Ne.
Na, das Waveline-Karte ist dein Modem. Sie wandelt die digitalen Signale in analoge Funkfrequenzen um. Das ist das, was ein Modem tut und das ist das, was diese Karte tut.
Aber einen ISP braucht man ja trotzdem, ne?
Das sind halt auch Wavelanen und da... Also du brauchst natürlich einen ISP, der dir es erlaubt, dich mit ihm per Wavelanen zu verbinden. Das heißt, wir brauchen eine Antenne auf dem Dach und du brauchst eine Sichtverbindung dahin. Oder du brauchst halt eine entsprechende Verbindung zu jemand, der so eine Verbindung hat.
Also wenn du zum Beispiel jetzt Quakespielen willst mit deinen Kumpels, die auch im gleichen Neubau-Block wohnen, dann brauchst du einfach nur deine Waveline-Karte ins Fenster zu stellen und kannst mit den Kumpels Quakespielen. So ist das.
Für die Karte, also die minimale Konstellation ist, du schiebst deine Waveline-Karte in deinen Laptop oder in einen PC, der mit entsprechenden PC-Card-Slots ausgestattet ist. Dann brauchst du noch mal so einen Adapter und die Karte kriegst du derzeit für 400 Mark tendenzfallend.
Dann musst du aber auch am Fenster spielen.
Genau. Oder du machst dann eine richtige Antenne dran, dann musst du noch mal für 90 Mark so einen Adapterschwanz reinstecken und dann musst du noch bei Konrad eine brauchbare Antenne kaufen. Dann kannst du auch mal einen Kilometer oder zwei weg sein.
Oder du stellst dir eine Route aufs Fensterbrett ordentlich BALAM.
Ich darf ja die Vorstellung so klasse, oder du stellst dir eine Route aufs Fensterbrett.
Das ist ja diese Maschine, von der ich vorhin redete, die sowieso Router macht. Wenn man da halt auch noch Waveline reinsteckt, dann deckt die halt entweder ab der Waveline auch noch die Ethernet-Verbindung ab oder eben auch im Haus.
Wenn es im richtigen Zimmer steht, das ist bei uns nicht der Fall. Deswegen steht das Notebook auf dem Pappkartons irgendwie. Und es nervt mich, wenn wir schlafen mit der Fiepen im Platte.
Schalt's doch aus.
Genau.
Nein, dann klingelt das Telefon.
Wir versuchen seit Jahren, dich zu erreichen. Wir haben ja teilweise, bei zwei unserer Standorte haben wir ja die Router auf dem Dach zu stehen. Und es ist wichtig, dass möglichst viele Leute über diesen Router ins Internet angebunden sind. Dann braucht man nämlich nur noch ein Schild an den Router ran zu machen. Denkt gar nicht dran. Weil wenn dann irgendjemand versucht, das zu klauen, dann geht das so schnell, dass da irgendjemand steht und...
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich bräuchte eigentlich ein bisschen Hardware.
Stimmt.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Die dürfen auch nicht so potent sein, oder? Als Rechner.
Aber man überschätze nicht die Gewaltbereitschaft von Nerds, denen das Netz verbunden hat.
Diese ganze Wireless-Networking-Boom dauert nur genauso lange, bis es hier jemand für 70 Mark im Monat eine Megabit anbietet. Dann nimmt ihr alles wieder weg, dann gehen alle Antennen wieder vom Dach, weil kein Stress mit Megabit für 70 Mark. Also die Situation ist nur, weil hier Internet so beschissen ist.
Na das gibt es ja im Prinzip auch schon. Die Telekom bietet ja dieses ominöse TDSL.
Er hängt noch in der Leitung. Du bist so weit durch, oder? Alles klar, ich leg da mal auf, kostet dein Geld.
Alles klar, tschau, danke.
Es gibt ja dieses TDSL, und dieses TDSL ist ja im Prinzip schon so was sehr Ähnliches. Also vielleicht nicht gerade mit 768 Kilobit, aber das ist ja auch schon ganz ordentlich. Und genau genommen ist das ja ein ATM-Anschluss, und nicht etwa ein besonders Anschluss, wo man nur an T-Online dran kann. Eigentlich ist das genau das, was man haben will. Man kann da breitbandig Verbindungen herstellen, und zwar auch zu anderen, und man kann da sehr preiswert innerhalb der Stadt, für 15 Mark Aufpreis, von der Telekom eine Verbindung von A nach B bekommen. Es geht auch mit Wehrverbindungen und so weiter. Nur ist das aus marketingtechnischen Gründen, wird es halt als TDSL verkauft, und damit kann man nur an T-Online, wenn man das gleiche als T-ATM kauft, dann hat man einen vollwertigen ATM-Anschluss, und dann hat man eben genau diese Situation Megabits im Haus, und man kann die frei vermittelt benutzen.
Aber nicht für 70 Mal?
Naja, genau genommen fragt man sich warum. Man fragt sich warum, weil es ist genau der gleiche Anschluss.
Ja, weil sonst verarschen.
Ja genau, weil du verarschst.
Eine Minute Mobiltelefon 40 Pfennige, ist doch genau so ein Blödsinn.
Ja, es ist alles definitiv zu teuer. Ich weiß auch nicht ganz genau, es scheint so ein bisschen Kultur zu sein hier in Deutschland, aber Deutschland hat sich einfach schwer einen eingebrockt, dadurch, dass sie nie wirklich offensiv gegen diese Monopolstellung der Telekom vorgegangen ist, und das alles ewig rausgezögert hat. Und ich meine, noch nie hat dieses Unternehmen das geboten, was wirklich gefragt war. Also es gab da noch nie das Angebot, was wirklich alle wollen, und jetzt wollen alle einfach Internet, flat und schnell, und es gibt halt immer noch niemanden, der es anbietet. Es ist halt auch ein bisschen müßig, das am laufenden Meter zu beklagen, aber es muss schon...
Die Telekom bietet das doch an. Du kriegst TDSL, flat für 100 und ein bisschen. 768 qubit. Was würde man denn dagegen sagen? Mit Flatrate, ohne Volumen.
Schnell, aber die Tagte, da hängt doch ein Zeitakt dran.
Nein.
Das ist die ganz normale T-Online-Flatrate. Nur, dass du halt einen ADSL-Anschluss kriegst.
Ist das nicht begrenzt? Sie haben jetzt 100 Stunden frei oder sowas?
Die wollen einfach die Technik pushen. Und da muss das Zeug natürlich raus. Es muss erstmal anmachen, damit die Geschichte überhaupt anläuft. Und deswegen machen die das.
Und damit kommst du nur an T-Online dann aber an?
Nein.
Weil es ist ja genau dieser ATM-Anschluss.
Technisch ist dieser Anschluss, den du als TDSL kaufst, in der Lage, als vollwertiger digitaler Anschluss für beliebige Dienste verwendet zu werden. Im Moment, wenn du den als TDSL kaufst, dann gibt es da genau einen Kanal, und der ist geschaltet zu T-Online. Aber man kann auf diesem Anschluss beliebige andere Verbindungen auch herstellen. Ich könnte jetzt zu jemandem anders, der auch einen TDSL-Anschluss hat, eine 100-Kilobit-Verbindung schalten und dann direkt Daten zu Impfungen ohne Internet und ohne das Thema Frankfurt, sondern direkt mit Telefon. Das ist gar nicht so schlimm. Man hat ja da auch zwei Schnittstellen. Man hat einmal dieses komische Ethernet-Interface, und dann ist da ein ATM25-Interface drin. Auch bei den Terminal-Adaptoren, die man für TDSL kauft. Das ist also nur eine Konfigurationsfrage und eine Marketingfrage.
Das Wort DSL hat hier die Leitungen glühen lassen.
Ich gehe mal ran.
Hier ist Chaosradio, hallo.
Ey, da kommt man doch mal ran.
Zu den Elektrosmog, ich finde es ein bisschen hart, dass ihr das als esoterischen Quatsch abhandelt. Ja gut, aber das summiert sich doch alles. Dann kommt dann noch die ganzen Funknetze dazu, telefonmäßig.
Und ich weiß ja nicht, das ist ohne Ende Wellen.
Leben gefährdet die Gesundheit, kann ich dazu nur sagen.
Dann darfst du doch bei Sonne nicht rausgehen, wie wir das machen.
Ja und wie ist denn das dann bei diesem Wireless-Laden? Das ist doch nur Point-to-Point-Verbindung, oder?
Nein.
Alles klar.
Ist wie Ethernet. Also du hast halt diesen Access-Point. Es gibt mehrere Modelle, du kannst verschiedene Konfigurationen fahren. Es gibt Point-to-Point. Aber es ist vor allem dafür gedacht, dass du eine Base-Station hast, so einen sogenannten Access-Point, dass der sozusagen wie so ein Ethernet-Hub im Prinzip.
Kriegt der da eine NAT oder wie läuft das?
Er kann NAT machen, er muss aber nicht NAT machen. Er macht in der Regel ein normales Ethernet-Bridging. Das heißt, er stellt eigentlich nur das, was auf dem Ethernet ist, ins Netz bereit und sammelt das entsprechend von den Clients ein. Also in einer typischen Firmenkonfiguration kannst du deine IP-Adresse einfach beibehalten. Willst bloß nicht deinen internen Ethernet-Port oder deine Fitze-Card, die du in der Seite drin hast.
Gibt es halt einfach die IP von dem Router als Gateway an?
In der ganzen IP-Konfiguration ändert sich überhaupt nichts, gar nichts. Das ist genauso wie Ethernet.
Du ersetzt praktisch nur deine Welfleinkarte durch deine Netzwerkarte.
Das ist eine Karte durch Luft.
Das ist der ganze Unterschied.
Ich bin ja mal gespannt, ob so was hier in Steglitz funktioniert bei den ganzen Hochhäusern.
Gut ist.
Na, geht. Also was willst du überbrücken?
1500 Meter?
Mit so einem Booster geht das doch, oder?
Sichtverbindung?
Wenn du Sichtverbindung hast, geht das?
Naja, nicht ganz.
Sichtverbindung, ein paar Bäume sind dazwischen. Das macht nix.
Ja, vergesst Booster. Du hast eine gute Antenne, ein Yagi. So ein Stab mit diesen kleinen Stäbchen dran. Und das dann einfach aus dem Fenster.
Das ist ja fast wieder wie CB-Funk, ein Grinsen.
Hier ist Chaosradio, hallo.
Ich hab mal eine Frage, also erst mal zu dem, der von mir gefragt hatte, wegen Funk, wegen dem Satelliten-Internet da. Es gibt einen Anbieter irgendwie, das Strato oder so, ist voll scheiße, aber macht ja nichts. Hat doppelt die ESDN-Jeschwindigkeit für 30 Mark Downstream im Monat, Übertragungsrate unbegrenzt. Man braucht einen Plus, bevor man einen Download macht, einen Upstream, um den Download auszuwählen. Danach kann man dann die Verbindung trennen. Natürlich habe ich auch eine Satelliten-Rin, aber eine Satelliten-Card, so viel dazu. Und jetzt zum Thema, ich glaube nicht, dass ich hier durchsetze, weil es ja auch relativ einfach zu stören oder nicht. Weil die Scheiße in Deutschland ist einfach das Telekom, die die ganzen Telefonleitungen hat in Amerika, die der Firma wirklich eigene Telefonnetze und dadurch kann man auch ihre eigenen Preise bestimmen. Das ist das Problem in Deutschland. Das Beste wäre, jeder Anbieter hat seine eigenen Leitungen eben und stellt die an zur Verfügung.
Den USA-Vergleich habe ich nicht ganz nachvollziehen können. Wem gehört da alles?
Na, das ist nicht so, dass über das Telekom, dass dir in Deutschland alles gehört, die ganzen Leitungen, und nur von anderen Firmen benutzt wird, denn dann hat eben jede Firma ihre eigenen Netze.
Na gut, ich meine, hier werden auch viele Netze aufgebaut, viele neue Datennetze. Es gibt mittlerweile einige Firmen, die halt städteübergreifend eigene Netzinfrastruktur anbieten und in dem ganzen ISP-Verkehr, also von Provider zu Provider, läuft. Bei Leib nicht alles über die Leitung der Telekom, sondern die haben halt natürlich auch welche, gar keine Frage. Aber da gibt es eben auch andere Anbieter, die dann auch billiger sind. Das Problem ist aber eigentlich die letzte Meile, also die eigentliche Überbrückung, weil das geschieht halt in der Regel über den Kupferdraht. Und dieser Kupferdraht, der in Deutschland aus Steuergeldern in den letzten 50 Jahren versenkt wurde, der wurde halt diesem Unternehmen geschenkt. Und wurde ihm einfach gesagt, dass es jetzt eures, das dürft ihr jetzt verkaufen, aber wir machen auch ein paar Regeln, wie ihr das verkaufen dürft. Und das tun sie halt derzeit. Und Wavelan ist ein Weg, einfach vollständig an diesem Kupferkabel vorbeizukommen. Allerdings sind natürlich auch andere Telekommunikationsanbieter, die sich bei der Telekom diese Leitung mieten, wie z.B. Berlikom hier in Berlin, ein anderer Weg.
Naja, es ist so, dass dieses Spreisbandverfahren, was da bei Wavelan eingesetzt wird, dass das relativ störunempfindlich ist, weil sich die Trägerfrequenz dauernd ändert. Das heißt, wenn man da mit einer...
Es gibt sogar keine Trägerfrequenz.
Das heißt, es ist eine Sendung ohne Träger.
Ja gut, aber... also gut, ja. Aber du kannst dich direkt eine Übertragung stören dadurch, dass du auf einer bestimmten Frequenz sendest, sondern du musst diese Sequenz, mit der gesendet wird, die musst du eben kennen, damit du das stören kannst.
Ich glaube aber kaum, dass jetzt irgendjemand so einen Love Parade Wagen macht, wo er irgendwie 20 Mikrowellen draufstellt, und auch einen Generator getrieben durch Berlin fährt, um irgendwie alle Waveladenverbindungen zu stören.
Rundlich illuminieren. Hier ist das Chaosradio.
Hier ist wahrscheinlich was für unseren Künstlerfreund. Wie heißt er noch gleich?
Was? Und zwar hatte ich mal eine Frage. Als alternatives Netz boot sichert das mal oder war mal im Gespräch das allgemeine Stromnetz und Stromkabel und so weiter. Wollte ich mal fragen, wie weit eigentlich die Technik und Entwicklung ist?
Das ist so ein bisschen so wie der Mythos mit dem Telefon, mit dem Fernsehkabelnetz.
Also, naja, Pilotprojekte.
Es gibt da halt Pilotprojekte und es gibt auch Firmen, die immer wieder der Meinung sind, ja, es läuft und wir werden es auch irgendwann tun.
Ist hier bloß in Deutschland so Gerücht und es wird immer, oder ist es in anderen Ländern schon so weit, dass sie sagen, ja, es läuft und so weiter und bloß hier in Deutschland ist es halt wieder nicht?
Soweit ich weiß, ist es nirgendwo groß, dass man Internet über Stromkabel kriegt?
Nein, das gibt es noch nicht. Es gibt zwar diverse Entwicklungen in dieser Richtung, das ist deswegen interessant, weil halt da das Kupfer schon drin liegt, bloß das gibt noch keine funktionierende und weit eingesetzte Technologie. Also nur Feldversuche, aber das ist alles im Anfang relativ früh stehen geblieben, weil die erziehbaren Datenraten sehr niedrig waren. Und es gibt zwar immer wieder irgendwelche Leute, die sagen, sie hätten da das Eil des Kolumbus und sie wissen jetzt, wie es auch mit hohen Datenraten geht, aber das sehe ich noch nicht.
Die kalte Fusion.
Frage beantworten.
Ah, das ist er. Danke.
Heiße Fusion war eh besser.
Ja, macht mehr Bums.
Ja, eben und zwar richtig. Hier ist das Chaosradio. Wir reden über Funknetze. Du auch?
Ja, doch ein bisschen. Und zwar, wie weit kann man dieses Roaming treiben? Ich habe da so einen Kerl, mit dem ich uns ein paar Daten austauschen müsste. Bloß, der wohnt in Dresden.
Na, Roaming ist ja was anderes. Roaming ist ja nicht, dass du weit funkst, sondern Roaming ist, dass wenn du eine mobile Station hast, du von einer Basisstation in die nächste dich einbuchen kannst und deine Verbindung sozusagen mitgenommen wird.
Ja genau. Ich würde es organisieren können, dass ich hier genug Leute auftreibe, die mit mir und dem anderen kleinen Ethernet aufbauen.
Von hier aus Dresden?
Ja, das kriegt man so einen sehr unaren Charakter.
Du kannst die, wenn du zwei Yagis nimmst und Verstärker, dann kannst du so im Flachen so 40, 50 Kilometer kannst du überbrücken. Dann brauchst du zwei Yagis und das ist schon halbwegs professionell. Das machst du nicht mehr vor 2000, sondern für 6, 7000 Mark für die ganze, für die Strecke. Dann kannst du 40, 50 Kilometer überbrücken. Dann brauchst du aber höher Punkte.
Das ist nicht schlecht. Da bräuchte man also den Fernsehtum hier zu mieten und den Fernsehtum in Dresden. Dann klappt das auch.
Die machen nichts anderes.
Wir reden über Funknetze und zwar mit Leitung 2. Hier ist das Chaosradio. Hallo Herrmann.
Ich habe mal eine Frage. Wenn die Dinge so funktionieren wie Netzwerkarten, haben die auch so etwas wie MAC-Adressen?
Ja, das war genau das.
Kann man da noch rumspielen?
Ja, kann man selber einstellen.
Das ist ja wunderbar. Man hat alles, was man braucht.
Genau, kannst du schön Jetbeef machen.
Schön, mehr wollte ich gar nicht wissen.
Alles klar, danke für deinen Aufruf. Die Mülluhr und 30.
Erfolg durch einen Golden Goal von Zidane hat Frankreich zum zweiten Mal nach 1984 das Endspiel einer Europameisterschaft erreicht. Zidane verwandelte in der Verlängerung einen Handelfmeter zum 2 zu 1 Sieg über Portugal. Der portugiesische Fußballnational Fenercuelho erklärte unmittelbar nach der Niederlage seiner Mannschaft seinen Rücktritt. Entscheidung, der kubanische Flüchtlingsjunge Elian ist auf dem Weg in die Heimat. Er bestieg am Abend mit seinem Vater in Washington eine Chartermaschine. Der oberste Gerichtshof der USA hatte zuvor einen Eilantrag von Elians Verwandten aus Miami abgelehnt, mit dem sie die Rückkehr des sechsjährigen Jungen verhindern wollten. Maßnahmen, Bund und Länder wollen mit einer Zucht, einem Zucht- und Einfuhrverbot sowie schärferen Strafen die Gefahr durch Kampfhunde eindämmen. Brandenburg plant, die strengen bayerischen Bestimmungen für Hundehalter zu übernehmen. In Berlin soll ein Maulkorb und ein Leinenzwang für Kampfhunde eingeführt werden. Verschärfung. Brandenburgs Justizminister Schelter will härter gegen Raser und betrunkene Autofahrer vorgehen. So wolle man die Bundesratsinitiative Sachsens unterstützen, die für Jugendliche unter 25 Jahren ein striktes Alkoholverbot am Steuer vorsehe, sagte der CDU-Minister. Nach zwei Einzelschauer um 9 Grad, morgen Schlag bewirkt und etwas Regen, 15 bis 18 Grad.
Bisschen Verkehr?
Schade.
Kennen wir ja.
Kurzinform mit Falk Zielke, 0 Uhr und 32. Vielen Dank.
Endlich kann man ihn kaufen, den Soundtrack zur Jahreszeit. Ein guter Sommer von Victoria Park, mehr als eine Single, eine EP mit drei Songs und zwei Mixen.
Überall, wo es wirklich gute Scheiben gibt, und im Plattenladen.
Die Victoria Park, ein guter Sommer.
Chaosradio 51, der Endspurt noch 20 Minuten. Eigentlich ganz 19 Minuten. Hackschiff? Wollte ich nur mal gesagt haben.
Ja, wir gehen wieder hacken.
Ja, das letzte Jahr stand ja im Sommer unter dem Zeichen des Camps.
Und es war geil.
Ja, es hat uns auch alle sehr eingenommen.
Ja, vor allen Dingen Tim, den ich versucht hab zu interviewen.
Vollbeschrittene Debititätszustand in diesem Fall.
Ja, durchaus, ja.
Ja, dieses Jahr gibt es auch wieder eine Aktion. Diese Aktion findet diesmal an der anderen Seite von Deutschland statt.
Im Osten.
Und da gibt es ein Hangschiff.
Im Rheinland.
Im Rheinland, genau, die rheinländische Fraktion des Chaos Computer Club hat da ein Schiff gemietet, einen Ausflugsdampfer, der irgendwie so 400 Leuten Platz bietet. Und da wird es dann diverse Vorträge oder Podiumsdiskussionen geben und das obligate Local Area Network und Bespaßung auch auf anderer Ebene, sodass wir da sicherlich wieder chaosmäßig Spaß haben werden.
Genau, also wer Lust hat, kann da halt mitkommen. Das kostet auch nicht viel Geld. Das ist der 23.March, natürlich hier von Berlin aus gesehen, alles ein bisschen weit weg und möglicherweise liegt der Termin auf den Freitag, das ist der 4.August. Da muss man dann um 18 Uhr irgendwie an den Keimauern anlangen und ja, dann hüpft man halt mit oder ohne Rechner auf das Boot und dann wird die ganze Nacht irgendwie über den Rhein gekuttert. Es wird versucht, dort auch Internet anzubieten. Ich kann da noch nicht so viel sagen, ob wir es noch haben müssen. Darum geht es letzten Endes nicht. Das ist eher so ein peripheres Ding, aber es geht halt mal wieder um Spaß am Gerät. So als Sommerbetätigung, bevor wir uns dann halt Ende dieses Jahres wieder auf den nächsten Kongress stürzen.
Wenn irgendjemand von der werten Zuhörerschaft da gerne mit einem Bus mitfahren möchte, kann er mail an mail.berlin.ccc.de schreiben, wir wollen versuchen einen Bus zu organisieren und falls das ein Transportproblem gibt, bitte mailed euch.
Oder wenn ein Mitfahrtgelegenheit ist, dann schon.
Wo legt es ab?
Im Rheinland. Guckt mal auf unsere Website, oder auf der Website der Kölner www.köln.ch.
Ich wollte jetzt eigentlich eine Vorlage liefern, es legt den Bonn ab. Und man kann dann in Köln übrigens noch mal zusteigen, habe ich gelesen. Genau, das fand ich irgendwie eine ganz praktische Sache. Ich dachte, ich mache das jetzt irgendwie so.
Ja okay, ich kann jetzt.
Ich kann jetzt.
Es ist so, ich habe nachgeguckt.
Du bist informiert.
Ich bin informiert. Darf ich da auch kommen?
Nee, nee, nee. Das wird ganz entspannt werden. Also wir haben also auch nicht vor, da irgendwie großartig, also das soll keine besonders interne oder so Veranstaltung werden. Das wird einfach für alle und lustig wie immer werden.
Ja guck ich mal, krieg ich da frei, komm ich vorbei. Ja, mach das. Wir rufen noch Leute an, die wollen mit.
Es wird auch sicherlich Waveline geben, also man kann da sicherlich mit dem Laptop, mit der Karte auch irgendwie...
Das heißt, bis dahin sollte ich mir mein neues Powerbook geholt haben.
Wir gucken, wie weit die Waveline geht, wenn man das Powerbook in das Wasser wirft.
Hier ist Chaosradio, wer ist da?
Ich wollte eigentlich, zum Thema kann ich was gerne sagen.
Ja, warum rufst du dann an? Vielleicht kannst du was fragen.
Ich wollte eigentlich fragen, wo ich dich schon hatte. Weil, hier Jessica, die, die kennt nämlich nicht das Lied von den Mamas und den Papas.
Du bist total off-topic sozusagen.
Und?
Und das würden wir gerne irgendwie mal hören wollen, weil...
Ja, dann müsst ihr es euch wünschen. Dazu haben wir eine Sendung, die heißt Openbox, jeden Tag, also von Montags bis Freitags, von 7 bis 8 Uhr abends. Und genau in der Zeit kannst du unter derselben Nummer anrufen, die du gerade angerufen hast, und dann kannst du es dir wünschen.
Und hier der Datenstream von dem Lied direkt.
Wir versuchen immer noch über Funknetze zu reden übrigens. Das schöne ist ja, dass du diesen blöd Mann richtig geholfen hast. Er ist schon weg, er kann nicht mehr antworten. Das tut mir jetzt sehr leid, aber da blinkt es schon wieder. Vielleicht ist er das ja wieder. Hast du noch was vergessen? Per Baroni?
Das haben sie Angst vor uns.
Ehrfurchtsvoll knien sie vor dem Telefon wieder, als die Verbindung durchgeschaltet wurde.
Wer sagt denn eben, diese ganze Verfunknetzerei würde sich ja übrigen, sobald wir für 70 Mark ein Mbit kriegen? Warum?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob wir das noch machen, es ist wichtig, da mehr mal mitzuspielen, aber die Idee, da mit einer Stadt oder bundesweites Netz aufzubauen, um die Telekons, also da bin ich mir nicht zu sicher, da glaube ich gleich nicht dran.
Da fällt mir noch was ein, die Windows-Software für die Airport-Base Station.
Gibt's bald, ist ja ein Beta-Test, ich hab da Software geschrieben, damit das Apple Airport-Base Station auch vom Windows-PC aus konfigurierbar ist, damit man nicht eine App haben muss, wenn man das Ding nur braucht.
Ja, aber man will doch einen Apple haben, doch nicht?
Ja, ich...
Es gibt Leute, die wollen das nicht.
Ich hab mir das auch mal gefragt, aber dann hab ich Tim gerade im Auto gesehen. Nee, eigentlich ist meine Windows-Maschine gar so schlecht noch nicht. Ich bin ein zufriedener Microsoft-Benutzer.
Echt?
Ja.
Das ist nicht dein Ernst?
Das ist verblüffend. Also noch nicht mal ich bin ein zufriedener Microsoft-Benutzer und ich kann damit nicht mal umgehen.
Ich bin auch ein zufriedener Microsoft-Benutzer, ich benutze es eigentlich nicht.
Dann bist du ja kein Benutzer.
Du bist ein Unbenutzer.
Ich bin ein Familienbenutzer.
Ich würde es als Züge nicht einsetzen, aber als Client für mich...
Ich finde das auch völlig in Ordnung.
Ja, will ich. Man ist so lange damit zugeschissen worden, dass man sich so sehr daran gewöhnt hat, dass der Umstich auf etwas anderes fast unmöglich ist.
Mein Windows bootet in einer Minute, nicht in vier wie dein. Das ist ein 1400er CS mit einem 7.6.1 und diesem komischen Appearance-Manager, was sonst gar nichts mehr funktioniert.
Nein, das kann ich ja nur auch nicht finden.
Haben wir noch einen Ausblick? Also was habt ihr noch vor? Habt ihr vor, Berlin zu vernetzen damit? Oder ist das wirklich nur so ein...
Das heißt, wir machen das jetzt einfach. Wir benutzen das damit einfach. Und wir wollten mal anregen, dass das eine gute Idee ist. Und dass, wenn andere Leute das auch machen wollen, dass sie dann sich mit uns in Verbindung setzen können. Und wir sicherlich dann auch zu Erfahrungsausflüssen.
Wie ist der Server mit den hübschen Bildern, mit der grünen Antenne?
Das ist Dabo.
Das ist Dabo. Das hört sich an, als wäre es jetzt wieder was ganz anderes. dabo.cdwave.net Und da ist auch Kontakt. Ja, stimmt.
Ja, da kann man den E-Mail erreichen. Über chaos.oab.de erreicht man unsere Spam-Mailboxen. Da kommt immer so viel Spam an, das ist unglaublich. Und ja, mail.berlin.ccc.de zum Beispiel auch noch.
Wie muss ich mir das vorstellen? Also kann ich jetzt hingehen und sagen, ich möchte jetzt das gerne auch im Friedrichshain haben? Weil ich möchte das eigentlich ja gerne auch im Friedrichshain haben. Was muss ich denn da machen? Muss ich mich da irgendwie bei euch mit dranhängen? Also es reicht mir ja nicht, mir da einfach nur so eine Antenne hinzustellen. Also dann habe ich eine Antenne und da hängt hinten irgendein Rechner dran und mit dem kann ich dann so rumfunkend irgendwie. Richtig toll ist es natürlich nur, wenn man Freunde hat, Holger.
Darum geht es ja, deswegen haben wir auch diesen Begriff Nachbarschaftsnetze. Waveline ist halt eine Methode, wie man eben in seiner Umgebung, und manche Leute haben ja auch in der direkten Nachbarschaft manchmal Freunde. Und interessanterweise haben ja auch Freunde heutzutage auch Computer und reden den ganzen Tag von Internet. Und mit Waveline kann man halt so diese normalen Strecken von gegenüber, das Haus oder irgendwie der Park, wenn man aus dem Fenster guckt, kann man wunderbar abdecken. Und wenn man eben dann so weit geht, da wo Sichtkontakt besteht zu jemanden, den man kennt, kann man halt über Funk eine Verbindung machen, der wiederum woanders hin, wo er hingucken kann, über Funk eine Verbindung macht. Und wenn irgendeiner von denen halt auch Internet hat und einen Router richtig konfigurieren kann, dann kann man eben allen auch Internet machen. Beziehungsweise man hat einfach einen LAN, was sozusagen in dem Sinne Local ist, von ein bis zwei Kilometern oder sowas. Und nicht eben nur eine Strippe, die durchs Wohnzimmer geht. Das ist eigentlich das Ding. Beziehungsweise ist es auch wunderbar, um ein ganzes Haus anzuschließen. Also wenn man jetzt an so besetzte Häuser denkt oder andere WG-Kulturen, die es in Berlin eine ganze Menge gibt, wo sie sicherlich auch Netzbedarf haben. Der eine, der angerufen hat, meinte ja, da braucht man keine Kabel zu verlegen. Das ist halt auch der Punkt. Das ist gerade für die Hausvernetzung optimal. Und man kann sich eben eine möglicherweise teure oder noch zu teure Internetverbindung, wie zum Beispiel dieses DSL, wunderbar eben unter vielen Leuten aufteilen. Das sind, finde ich, sehr lobenswerte Ansätze, technische.
Finden die DSL-Anbieter das dann witzig?
Das kann den einfach mal und muss den einfach mal egal sein.
Das ist auch nicht für deren Amüsement, sondern für uns. Das ist klar, ja.
Und das hat man unter Garantie.
Aber ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass die dann auch in ihre AGBs schreiben. Das da bitte nur ein Rechner hinten da hinten.
Ja, natürlich, das können sie doch auch gerne machen.
AGBs Urheberrecht Grundbesitz. Die mussten uns da rücken und weniger weiß bemerken.
Grundbesitz ist das andere als Urheberrecht. Dieses Urheberrecht ist einfach eine irrige Idee, der jetzt so angehangen wird und so getan wird, als wäre das irgendwie Gott gegeben worden.
Das ist gar nicht der Fall.
Ich habe noch nie jemanden getroffen, der eine Idee hatte, die nicht auf Ideen von anderen Leuten basiert hat. Das wird es auch nicht geben. Deswegen ist es einfach Quatsch. Genau wie Patente eigentlich Quatsch sind.
Ja, das habe ich auch immer gesagt.
Was ist immer noch deine Meinung?
Willst du drüber reden oder malst du ein Bild?
Ja, aber darum geht es nicht.
Wir wollen jetzt hier keine Urheberrechtsdiskussion machen. Das machen wir sicherlich in einer der nächsten Sendungen, weil das ist auch noch mal zwingend nötig. Das hatten wir auch und müssen wir auch glaube ich noch ein paar Mal machen. Aber hier geht es jetzt erstmal um Spaß angeregnet.
Ja, aber kann man den denn haben, wenn man Urheber... Das ist mein Scherz. Apropos eine der nächsten Sendungen, ich habe es erst einmal gesagt, ich sage es vielleicht noch mal, wir treffen uns hier nicht mehr Mittwochs. Ohje, ich weiß, dass du jetzt ohje sagst, sondern wir treffen uns fort an Montag, und zwar am jeweils letzten Montag im Monat. Die nächste Sendung wird also am 31.07 sein. Das ist ein Montag. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Da gibt es Chaosradio. Zumindest hoffe ich, was für ein Thema das sein wird.
Das Thema wissen wir, glaube ich schon.
Das wirst du mir wahrscheinlich einen Tag vorher sagen.
Du wirst lachen, wir wissen das bereits.
Wann ist denn das? Am 31.07. Das ist ein Montag.
Das Thema wird sein Programmier-Sprachen. Nein, das ist das Thema.
Das ist Terror.
Das ist Terror und da würde ich dich bitten, mir die Expertenfragen vorher aufzuschreiben, die ich stellen soll.
Kein Problem.
Können wir machen.
Jörn ist jetzt auch drauf. Jörn hat es jetzt endlich geschafft, aus Bremen, nach 175 Minuten Chaosradio auf den Hill-Audio-Sauer drauf zu kommen. Das ist wirklich ein Helden-Tag.
Hat sich denn am Rosenthaler Platz eigentlich jemand eingefunden? Okay, ihr habt die kostenlose Internet-Option im Sushiladen sozusagen jetzt verpasst.
Naja, aber ich meine, er ist doch weiterbestehend.
So lange bis da ein Passwort drauf kommt.
Hey, hier klingelt das Telefon. Wollen wir nochmal rangehen? Joey's Pizza. Guten Abend. Hier ist Chaosradio.
Das Niveau sieht aus wie eine Hosenzahlstein.
Vielleicht sollten wir das einfach beenden.
Das ist jetzt schon kühn, aber... Alter Vier.
Ich kriege hier gerade so eine mittlere Krise, weil ich gar nicht weiß, wer das ist. Ich bin vor eins, der die Sendung hier nach übernimmt. Die Sendung heißt Night Flight. Ah, Martin Petersdorf. Martin Petersdorf ist der, den ich nachts um eins immer mit dem Soundgarden ankündige, aber das mach ich heute nicht. Hier jetzt gleich Martin Petersdorf mit dem Night Flight und das war das Chaosradio 51 im Studio Hans, der gerade ganz komisch guckt. Hans, Hans. Okay, es geht wieder.
Ich musste gerade niesen, das geht dann wieder doch nicht.
Ach so, das war ganz schüchtern, das war ein Gesichtszügen. Außerdem im Studio Tim, Rob und Philipp.
Und jede Menge Drogen.
Lack uns gewogen, nichts für ungut. Und Pizza, könnt ihr euch selber holen.
Und vernetzt eure Heime.
Genau. Wir sehen uns in den Medien.